so we have this crazy story came out
yesterday that there was there were
secret commandos deployed on january 6
with shoot to kill authority now we
started about a minute or so late
because the initial story i had read
said that trump had deployed them and i
think that was incorrect so we wanted to
change the headline and then actually
have a discussion about uh what it
really means it was the doj it was
apparently i think rosen who deployed
these commandos to prevent a terror
attack i don't know if it actually came
from donald trump want to make sure that
was clear but this is a huge this is
huge if it was the the executive branch
that was trying to shut this thing down
i think it's it's still incorrect to
claim that there was an insurrection
narrative uh or the insurrection
narrative is completely absurd to begin
with and this is just more evidence to
the fact that the media is completely in
the wrong about what happened on january
6th but there's there's a there's a
better story outside of all of this that
i think is the big news the lead there's
also a really funny story if an election
was held today
joe biden would lose to donald trump the
nation supports trump by an average of
five points above joe biden in aggregate
not any single poll and if the
mainstream media is maintaining their
narrative that trump is currently
involved in a conspiracy to overthrow
american democracy and that there was an
insurrection or a coup that would mean
that americans knowing this support it
more than joe biden which says a whole
lot about what their narrative is but
we'll have to break down the news to
make sure we get it absolutely correct
there's a bunch of other stories the
daily mail has joined getter which is
huge because once getter becomes a
utility for news gathering you're going
to see way more people signing up so
that's a big deal 500 000 people
reportedly signed up for signed up for
getter after the joe rogan episode and
we've also got reports about lockdowns
coming in canada and believe it or not
bernie sanders will face a primary
challenge from the left joe biden joe
bidenwill
what what what
speak jack
bernie sanders campaign manager says
that joe biden oh joe biden will face
the primary challenger and since it's
bernie sanders manager
i guess
i totally screwed that one up thank you
thank you for correcting me on that one
jack um so okay then well as all of you
know live fact checking live live chat
live chat i got that one wrong uh jack
what's going on
what's going on welcome back merry
christmas happy new year to everybody
it's been a minute uh i've got my my
baidual t-shirt on which is which is
tim's favorite word in mandarin but tim
why don't you tell us what does
bideswell mean white left white left
it's mandarin
and the the subtitle is uh chyna figured
it out we didn't right and so this is
actually sent to me by the myth and
former guys for christmas merry
christmas guys uh you you a bunch of
filthy atheists and um
now it's really cool this is the idea
that that in in the west right we are
sort of controlled by the grip of this
like fearsome minority of the white left
where they're just these angry little
but you know very vocal and loud
screaming leftists that are all
typically white and have this undue
influence in the west for some reason
and china figured this out and made it a
joke years ago
we saw this with pat oswalt he's a
perfect example i mean he's like i've
been friends with dave chappelle for
three four years apologize
i'm gonna apologize for being friends
with the guy who created and starred in
chappelle show
right
you know who's one of the pr probably
the most prominent comedian in the
country right now i mean how could you
could you think of anyone that's more
prominent rogan than chappelle the two
of them i mean
is rogan just a comedian though though
no he's like that because he's more than
i mean he's prominent
but i think he's prominent for being
other than just his comedy we'll we'll
get into this yeah we got we got luke
here yeah
thank you so much
and uh
yeah
i'm impressed uh he's been working on
that but anyway today i am wearing a
shirt representing joe biden in his
natural essence and habitat that of
course is a puppet with the saying who's
really in charge that's a big question
and of course that's left to a lot of
interpretation but it gets a lot of
people thinking and if you want to do
that you can by just getting this shirt
on the best political shirts.com and
supporting me at the same time i'm
excited for this conversation yeah check
it's going to be fun it's going to be
interesting and we also have a new
person joining us that came back that
wasn't here this year at all
i just got hired first time all year
since last year
my first time on tv guys so be nice to
me hey i'm back guys one of last
season's uh what's up dudes uh i had you
survived langley's man it was wild i
fell asleep on the plane i don't
remember much after that
did you see any walnuts that were
possibly airborne i i almost screamed at
you just now
possibly airborne yeah yeah yeah yeah
they're born walnuts
yeah
it's langley's at the end we were like
yeah and then it like pauses in mid-air
where they're like jumping freeze frame
i don't think so cheap movie no i never
i never saw the
wait that might have been what's really
funny is
i've only ever watched language once but
i was on an airplane and i never saw the
ending because i fell asleep oh there
you go dirty common problem dude i
promised him i was gonna start wearing
jeans on the show and no longer warm up
with jams i'm going professional this
year but i got to show you guys this i
came home yesterday he's wearing
projects and i found these oh my gosh
who would send me such crazy and amazing
pajama pants it was lukeward caskey
those are super i was like those look
new yeah you've got to wear pants
come on dude i was like tonight this is
a professional environment tonight we're
going to smooth it in the office
i love you guys thank you so much i had
an amazing time away from the tv for a
little while and i highly suggest doing
the same for yourself for your state of
mind be good yourself and your friends
and your family now is the time amen
right on we got lydia yeah i'm here as
well we were talking about polarity
before the show tonight which is always
great source of freaking dad jokes and i
did want to say that i remember when the
chinese went from making fun of the
bites wow to like weaponizing that that
was totally worth it that's right it's
very smart all right everybody before we
get started head over to timcast.com and
become a member we're gonna have a
special members only podcast that goes
live around 11 or so p.m we do that
monday through thursday so it'll be of
course with jack here and as a member of
timcast.com you're supporting all of our
journalists all of the work we're doing
and we are constantly innovating and
expanding and working on more amazing
projects hiring more journalists the
more the more you guys sign up the more
we expand and do the the news reporting
we get a ton of people working here now
i think it's like up to like 32 maybe
and that's all thanks to you so again go
to timcast support our work check out
the store where you can buy awesome
merch like this shirt that says don't be
that guy be a gorilla and if you
understand the meme it's the alex jones
meme when he came in came in here and he
kept saying
over and over again and we decided to
make a positive thing we don't want to
tell people we don't want to make i'm
not that guy no no don't be that guy be
a gorilla be strong be confident be you
know we were like we need a positive
message here but don't forget you can
also subscribe to this channel smash the
like button share the show with your
friends let's read this this story here
this is this is from newsweek came out
the other day secret commandos with
shoot to kill authority were at the
capitol
on sunday january third the heads of a
dozen elite government special
operations team met in quantico virginia
to go over potential threats
contingencies and plans for the upcoming
joint session of congress the meeting
and the subsequent deployment of these
shadowy commandos on january 6 has never
before been revealed
right after the new year jeffrey rosen
the acting attorney general on january 6
approved implementation of long-standing
contingency plans dealing with the most
extreme possibilities an attack on
donald trump or vice president mike
pence a terror attack involving a weapon
of mass destruction and a declaration of
measures to implement continuity of
government requiring protection and
movement of presidential successors
rosen made a unilateral decision to take
the preparatory steps to deploy the
justice department's so-called national
forces there was no formal request from
the u.s capitol police the secret
service or the metropolitan police
department in fact no external request
from any agency the leadership in
justice and the fbi anticipated the
worst and decided to act independently
special operations forces lurking behind
the scenes so here's the question i have
with this story
if they knew all of this
if they had the foresight to say there
was a very serious threat where was the
national guard where were the capital
police why weren't they sharing
intelligence why weren't they doing
anything to prevent the so-called it's
almost like they wanted it to happen
so i i can i can explain to everybody a
couple of things here if you want um
so there was that bit so right before we
started there was a question of because
i think tim you had seen on the daily
mail the way they categorized this i
think it was daily mail it was it may
have been the other meal that that trump
had deployed these teams right which
changes things but if you read through
what it states is is that trump had
approved the authority for these teams
but
trump approved the authority for these
teams back during the summer of 2020 and
he had put the order in because remember
the riots were going on late may early
june 2020 horrific the city of dc was on
fire hold on trump authorized
commandos with shoot to kill authority
because of the george floyd riots so
yes and no uh well yes right it's not
like it's not like he specifically said
that but this it look this is this what
we would call this as the ncr con up so
the ncr conop and if tom sauer were here
he would know exactly what i'm talking
about that essentially means if there is
a threat to the national capital region
that's kind of like all bets are off
like this is the head of the government
right so if there is a threat to the
national capital region that that stuff
just in place you just press the button
and boom all this stuff gets spun up and
it gets spun up real fast and so i
believe and i knew and i reported some
of this
back when it happened um but there were
reports that the 82nd airborne was
flying airborne remember those uh
helicopters that you saw over dc during
the summer of 2020. so let me just put
it this way if the 82nd is up in the air
who do you think is on those birds right
who do you think is operating on the
ground if you can see the 82nd up in the
air right it's just one of those like
common sense kind of things like just
think about this that's tier one
response because if the head of
government goes down right who else is
left like you need to defend the capital
and so
they do not play any jokes but they do
not mess around with that stuff and so
we already knew that barr during the
summer of 2020 had taken the step to
deputize
all federal law enforcement agencies
remember this this was reported i know
you've talked about it are you talking
about oregon in throughout the entire
country all three letter agencies that
were 1811 so if you have an 1811 that
means you're a special agent so if
you're
uh customs and border patrol under dhs
if you're a secret service if you're um
even even irs right has 1811's that's
that's your special agent federal law
enforcement that means i'm a federal
agent right federal agent right that's
1811. so
in 1811 however is not normally tasked
with or your bureau of prisons for
example that's had they have 1811's
you're not usually tasked with defending
the capital barr put forward the this is
the same reason why boratak which is the
special ops unit for the border went up
to oregon right so bard put out this
blanket order so a bunch of these black
and orders were signed during that
period this is one of them however i
don't think trump ever considered that
it would be used at the capitol during
this interesting however because the
authority was already signed rosen
looked at it and said yeah sure send
them the capital they didn't do anything
though
so we know oh i see see what i think i
think the reason this is why is this
coming out in newsweek now
why when there's been so many questions
about january 6
when this has been front page news even
though by the way the ratings on
anything related to january 6 they're in
the dumpster right nobody in like the
rest of the country is really caring
that much about this and the opinion
polls bear this out
that you have one narrow band of people
that like really really care about it
and they all watched rachel maddow and
enjoy reid and a lot of them are in the
white house currently like ron clayne um
but other than that people have kind of
moved on they care about inflation they
care about the gas prices etc but
suddenly you've got people like like
darren beatty like myself who have been
out there talking about you know tucker
carlson had this huge documentary about
what was going on with federal agents in
terms of this we're one year away from
it we know that the january 6 committee
has been continuing to go after hannity
now they're going after other people
kennedy they knew they are they've
they've just requested his um you know
they've requested his assistance and
then if he doesn't comply that'll be
next episode did they request uh
documents from you
i have not been i have not had any
communication with january
uh committee and
then um
where was i on that okay so
they know that something is going to
come out regarding this they remember
they all talked called tucker carlson
crazy they said tin foil hair on fire
for suggesting that federal agents from
these agencies may have been involved on
january 6 are involved with any of these
militias or anything like that and now
suddenly we get these people coming out
on their own i see to say well okay we
did have special operations commandos
but they were only there to protect they
were only there to do this and we
guarantee they weren't doing anything
else so you you think that some of these
guys were involved with um effectively
planning or pushing people towards
things like that i don't want to i don't
know i don't want to say that guy's name
necessarily like but there's a guy who
everyone's accusing of being a fed yeah
and i don't even know if it would be
that far but i would guarantee you that
at some level if these guys were doing
their jobs they would be hint they would
be running operations they would be
dressing up plain clothes they would be
going into the crowd they would be
saying hey what are you guys doing after
what are you doing after the after the
thing you guys you're giving up the
capital maybe i think the narrative is
already i think that's all going to come
out well the the idea that the doj had
enough foresight to prepare to have
special operations on the ground
suggests that for some reason they did
not have
standard law enforcement police or
national guard that they were they were
so worried about a terror attack that
they get a handful of these commandos
why not go talk to the police and say
hey look we think this is a serious
threat so why don't you beef up security
which by the way in that video
you're you're right don't bury the lead
there was a terror attack there were
pipe bombs that were planted on january
5th the night before at the rnc at the d
and the dnc i'm like
you know i i get that you want to go
after like rolling up you know uh magami
maws and everything in alaska but i'm a
little bit more worried about who was
planting the pipe bombs
you know
at the heads of our national committees
for both parties the intelligence
agencies definitely lost the vegas
shooter that thing yeah yeah steven
paddock the guy definitely one way of
expressing it largest mass shooting in
u.s history and yet we don't even know
anything about this motive and then the
fact the fact that that we had this
incident you know all over washington dc
which is a surveillance grid which is
has surveillance cameras everywhere you
had someone leaving pipe bombs and they
still haven't caught the person next to
the cabinet people don't know the
capital
as well there's a number of pipe bombs
that day and this of course leads to a
lot of speculation a lot of conspiracy
theories that there was a plan b if
something didn't work out that they
would use this as a as a rich as you've
seen you've seen the blue on thing on
this right yeah who they claim who it is
oh no i don't see that you haven't seen
those they claim what's up there is a
blue and on thing out there where they
claim that the pipe bomb because of
what is it
there there's like some reason that they
say from the video i don't know if it's
the sneakers or the walk or something
blue and on actually claims that the
pipe bomber was marjorie taylor green
i i kid you not
like you can go go look it up they they
actually have i don't know if there's
articles but you can find it on like tik
tok and stuff where they say yeah that
we think it was marjorie taylor green
and they have these whole theories and
like where was she the night before etc
they're making fake tweets about it
no no no joke daily dot fake tweet
attempts to link marjory taylor green to
capitals daily dot is like as far left
crazy as you can go
i'm kind of with you here jack i i think
the federal government is more
implicated here than we nee we even know
about it
wait wait look at this same gate same
left arm swing same dropped left
shoulder shoes look the same it turns
out it was a human wait wait wait guys
guys
dark pants whoa whoa whoa dark naturally
pants were both worn by marjorie taylor
green that's a shadow and the pipe
bomber casper is a shadow roller
suitcase she has a roller suitcase she
has a roller bag too she also has a
roller bag nobody has a roller no nobody
has
person
really
they stopped using those in the 90s
now everyone's got skateboards they
carry all their stuff and individually
wrapped plastic bags i'm gonna have to
be skeptical on this one i've been
watching a lot of information on
the the bombing of pearl harbor and that
i've heard that the american government
knew there was going to be an attack
they didn't know where so they they were
kind of they just let it happen because
they needed to incite the people to get
angry and go to war and i when i see
these like waiting letting it happen
they knew it was gonna they were there
just in case but they kind of let
something happen it looks like they
obviously didn't stop it
i i can't i can't uh well that's the
whole thing about like admiral layton
who was the n2 or the j-2 for pacom at
the time who was the intel director out
there before he was admiral he was
commander layton uh my navy buddies are
gonna be mad at me for that one he he
had predicted that it would come to
pearl harbor but nobody listened to him
yeah so there's a there's a couple
different ways people address that they
say either we had reason to believe it
was ignored we had intelligence it was
ignored or they outright knew it was
about to happen and said stand down we
need it well it's not that we didn't
miss that the the entire japanese fleet
left tokyo the idea is are they going to
hit the philippines are they going to
hit hong kong or are they going to hit
hawaii and what people don't realize
that they actually hit all three at the
same time but but i will say this
because i i can't speak to that stuff i
will say your the history people think
they know man if you had any idea and
the example i often give is if the news
are fake imagine history
take a look at occupy wall street
occupy wall street the story of what
went on in occupy wall street is
predominantly told by those who favored
occupy wall street the people who
opposed it weren't in the park so there
were very few people who are going to
give you an honest assessment of what
actually happened there and even the
people who might be there as actual
journalists couldn't see the the
entirety of the picture not even i could
not even loot could we were down there
but i'll tell you this the stuff i see
they write about occupying what was
going on i'm like man they just lie
about everything to make it seem good
what's going to happen is it's going to
be 20 30 years and they're gonna be like
we're gonna read this book on what
happened during occupy wall street and
it's gonna be all fluff all the bad
stuff stripped out and i'm sure the same
is true for american history and for the
revolution spanish civil war spanish
civil war there's probably a whole bunch
of really crazy gruesome awful stuff the
americans did during the war for
independence that just doesn't get told
about yeah dude the native american
genesis oh dude the conquest well i mean
it's conquest you look at the movie the
patriot with mel gibson which is a
fantastic movie and they talk about the
the you know what did he call it i don't
know the the
wilderness campaign the really brutal
stuff that this guy did there's there's
probably stuff you're never gonna hear
because the people who won were probably
like don't tell them what we had to do
to win give them a good victory story
that's actually why i like the movie
fury if you've seen that one oh really
you haven't seen that so this is the
movie any of you guys you know no so
brad pitt um i think shia labeouf is in
it a couple other people
um and it just show it's it's a story of
like one tank one tank unit uh in europe
and it's just
the it's the mud and the grit and the
dirt and like some kid comes up with you
know with an rpg and they've gotta shoot
the kid right or else he's gonna blow up
the tank and kill everybody and it's
just it's dirty and it's nasty and
there's this one
this one part where brad pitt has and
they have the german right and so the
child above has just joined the unit um
is kind of the plot of it and they've
got this nazi that they've captured and
they're like in brad pitt's like we
ain't got no room for prisoners here
with say the same command this ain't a
prisoner unit he's like you got
like he he's got a job his job is
killing you you got a job your job is
killing him are you going to do your job
are you going to let him do his job and
it's it's just like all these various
scenes like that culminating you know
the first thing he has to do is wash his
buddy's like face and guts out of the
tank because he's taken that seat yeah
i've seen that movie it was very oh yeah
now it reminded me exactly yeah you're
talking about this is what 99 of warfare
was like yeah and and there's also the
bombing of dresden which also
goes unaddressed and not talked about
what fdr knew about you know the camps
there's so much history that again we
just aren't privy to and so much of it
who infiltrated auschwitz twice was
writing reports from the ninth in the
early 40s back to so polish underground
intelligence officer infiltrates
auschwitz
sets up literally a radio relay from
inside the camp to get it out to the
polish underground they send the reports
back to the to the british the british
put it on a shelf yep wow fdr
and yeah fdr yeah let's talk about
modern sentiments because i want to stay
on the the the uh the january 6 topic we
have the story from newsweek biden
starts 2022 trailing trump by average of
nearly five points in 2024 election
polls now i would like you to all enter
the world view of the establishment left
they believe that donald trump staged a
military coup and failed they believe
that donald trump staged an insurrection
and failed they believe that he is
currently trying to engage in another
coup and another insurrection the
atlantic rights trump's next coup has
already begun january 6 was practice
donald trump's gop is much better
positioned to subvert the next election
combine these stories and you will start
to see a variant is this the one where
it's like you know people are running
for local
chair and stuff but look
there's another story that we talked
about on the show a few weeks ago where
it says the trump conspiracy is still
continuing if the atlantic if these
mainstream publications genuinely
believe that trump is actively engaging
in the subversion of u.s democracy it
means that the polls show
more americans favor the insurrection
and the coup than the establishment
government well i have a um
i have a i have a thing on this and i
was i was kind of joking around on
twitter yesterday and i said you know
all of the headlines make sense if you
re if you can learn to speak regime
english
and
english yeah i figured you'd like that
one and uh so if you speak regime
english so and i i lifted this bit from
um from adrian vermeuel and uh i don't
usually make it a habit of quoting
harvard professors but you know he's
kind of like a token you know good guy
so i'll quote him and he said when they
say democracy they really mean
liberalism right so just always always
substitute the word you know trump is a
threat to democracy trump is a threat to
liberalism just thinking to subvert
democracy trump is seeking to subvert
liberalism you see that but i don't
think liberalism is the right word
because they're a cult it's just
something entirely the liberal economic
order that thing they said
you see that clip that went viral where
you know they're like the republicans
are a threat to democracy because they
might win elections yeah this is it's
not a coup when you unseat a sitting
president through votes and win the
election that's a natural way that it
functions it might seem cool
because it's a new guy coming in
they they have right in their own mind
they have gone so far into their own
you could use the phrase of the day mass
formation psychosis where they actually
believe that democracy and liberalism
are synonymous that they're the same
thing there can be no other order and
this of course is not just a mass
formation psychosis thing this this is
actually religious belief right you know
there can only be one true religion so
if there can only be one true order then
anything that arises that's a threat to
that that's outside the overton window
of our order must therefore be against
all of democracy take a look at this
other story from timcast.com about half
of both republicans and democrats view
the other side as enemies that threaten
their entire way of life wow so maybe it
is true you know maybe
most americans if an election was held
today would vote for donald trump over
joe biden but here's the thing
those americans support donald trump
don't believe an insurrection happened
these are people who probably read the
news watch the news saw what's going on
and they're like that's ridiculous the
narrative isn't true because if they
truly believed that what trump did was a
military coup they probably wouldn't
support him but they don't because
military coup without the military or
without any guns and a bunch of yeah a
bunch of unarmed people most of us
through open doors and smiling police
you know and uh you know nancy pelosi if
you're watching right you know i think
and i said i think i said this on air
she doesn't not use the internet oh no
way i know but her little acolytes do um
that
i
the disparity here is that the people
inside the media and inside the democrat
party and inside the january 6 committee
say that every single person that showed
up on january 6 was anti-constitution
but if you talk to anybody who was in
the crowd on january 6 right you they
probably every single one of them would
have said no i am for the constitution
you're not following the constitution
and that's why we're here right so in
their mind they are the ones fighting
against a coup you get it right
in a way it's like the easiest solution
because neither one of them intend to
stage a coup they both think the other
one's doing what they're doing
or or
they the other one thinks that they're
doing what they think the other ones do
and like yeah but that's objectively
wrong yeah so how do you unwind that
here here's what i think when i see this
i think this is mostly a product of
the the incoming generation and uh
polarization from the previous
generation so
i don't think we're seeing this hyper
polarization just because people are
reading social media and becoming
polarized i think it's that younger
people who are more radicalized by the
previous generation or i think a fair
way to put it is when you look at the
pew graph conservatives have barely
moved to the right at all the left has
gone far left
you have
corporate america
and uh you know liberal parents in big
cities
pushing this heavy indoctrination i mean
my whole whole childhood growing up it
was just endless leftist you know
talking points so these people grow up
living in this world which is far left
they weren't converted to the far left
they have developed in a far-left
mindset yes so as time goes on it is the
new generations that are polarized
against each other what i mean to say is
two millennials one who is far left and
one who is conservative
weren't like previously friends who read
a news article and then went i now
disagree with you oh no why are we
enemies these are people who grew up in
entirely different realities and cannot
see the other side now it is true it is
the rule on the right the right does
read left-wing publications and does
follow left-wing individuals and it is
the rule on the left that they don't
we've gone through the graphs we've
pulled up many of those personalities
they don't read right-wing news so you
have the left that is in a collective in
an echo chamber and the right which you
know looks at both
they're not going to get along i've also
said though that this this one of the
biggest problems on uh you know of
conservatives or like you know
up until now is that conservatives will
pathologically
deny and reject the notion that pop
culture and hollywood have any effect on
society you know they they say oh no
those are just movies that's not real
don't worry about that whereas as you
just said
there's an inundation of left-wing
talking points out there and a lot of
that is coming through hollywood whether
that be tv movies
in some cases video games now where it's
coming in um and whereas if you're on
the right you're like oh well no we can
just separate that out and it's like no
that's not how it works i think the new
right is at least finally trying to get
that like software upgrade and
understanding no wait you know
we actually have to do something about
this because but it's amazing because i
will tweet something about this and say
hey i think this tv show or this movie
or whatever it is had a bunch of
influence in this direction and i will
get conservative saying oh that's crazy
that's ridiculous you can't talk about
this but what did barack obama do when
he was in office he would go on late
night shows he would go on comedy he
would do all this stuff he would appear
you know in things and people would say
and people on the right would just laugh
and they would attack it and they say it
was stupid he would go on youtube and
people would attack him and meanwhile on
the left they're like oh i like this guy
this guy's cool and this is the mistake
that the media made with trump when
trump had his well-done steak with
ketchup he had a was like a 30-day dry
age steak and he was well done with
ketchup yes and the media mocked him for
it but that made him more relatable to
middle america well just really quickly
this is why i think barack obama after
he left office started to work with
netflix with an exclusive deal 100 and i
would even go further than you jack i
wouldn't say it's talking points i would
say it's covert subliminal messaging
that of course is put on to people
through the forms of entertainment it's
not entertainment it's propaganda and it
it's it's fomented in a way where it's
not i don't think it's leftist
ideologies i believe the entire left has
been taken over by a corporate
establishment that is using them as a
conduit to push their agenda to make
people weaker to make people dumber to
make people more
needy for centralization which of course
is going to be granted and given to them
through the multinational corporation so
i think you know i wouldn't even
describe these as leftist ideas but more
of corporatist ideas with them really
calling the shots here from my
perspective is it just fascism
you know
big corporations and government
colluding with each other yeah it's a
new kind of digital fascism i mean
that's literal
but also now with the late latest
psychological tricks they could get in
our brain in ways that they never could
before especially with again social
media especially with how we interact
with them and all the information we
give them they have data sets that
dictators would have wished to have that
will again help them conquer the general
public because we're literally giving
them everything about us and when they
know everything they could weaponize
that and use it against us so
you have you guys seen don't look up yet
of course you've seen it so i thought it
was great one thing i i really enjoyed
it and i enjoyed the social commentary
and people were like lighting me up for
saying that i like this because
everybody gets cured in it but one thing
that i don't think people
realized very well is
the primary antagonist like the main
villain of the movie is a tech oligar
transhumanist globalist slash bill gates
yeah it's like bill gates
elon musk and like a hillary type no no
it's it shows a picture of the president
hugging bill clinton oh wow yeah like
and and it's irrelevant to the scene
when we were watching luke's like look
clinton clinton clinton and it's like
half a second i totally didn't know in
the middle of
a picture of the president hugging bill
clinton for no reason
and i'm like
i get it
at the very right so this i think is
this one of the first times that we've
seen that a tech oligarch has been
portrayed as the villain in a movie
kingsman uh kingsman yeah would be one
the circle i think would be another one
which like nobody has seen even though
it was tom hanks and emma watson they
totally memory hold that one because i
didn't think i saw it i barely remember
it i loved it i thought that really
really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really really really really really
really fantastic fantastic but one of
the key things in don't look up and that
one is that all of what lucas was
talking about they have all your data
and the way this is played out in don't
look up and it's i thought it was funny
he was like he's like i can actually
predict how you're going to die
down to
96.6 uh percentage and i looked up your
algorithm when when you left the one
thing i remember is you'll die alone
and there's also that amazon which i'm
not going to spoil it but
it was wrong that guy if you remember
the ending actually his prediction was
spoiler good i know a little bit of a
spoiler what was the amazon series that
they that they cancelled season two of
because it was too rare
utopia that was another
a tech billionaire who's worried about
overpopulation he makes fake me wait
wait and this was on amazon it's on
amazon
okay hold on it gets crazier let me let
me just let me get through this explain
it's going to be
attack billionaire
he makes fake meat he's concerned about
overpopulation and climate change so he
stages a fake pandemic to rush through a
vaccine before proper without proper
approval
that secretly is sterilizing people
you're still talking about a tv show tv
show i think so
i'm not done this isn't luke's ladies
in the show
there is a comic book that reveals
what the plan is and what's going on and
it's the comic book is called utopia and
so when they find it they're looking
through it to figure out clues for
what's happening in real life because
whoever wrote this has privy to
information so it's like a whistleblower
is writing the comments mad scientist so
that was a part of uh doing so let me
explain to you it's a tv show where they
find a piece of art and media that
explains them a tech billionaire who's
worried about overpopulation
is pushing a pushing through a rushed
vaccine with a fake pandemic to
sterilize people now now let's talk
about reality oh yeah
in the real world
we have a tv a piece of art that claims
to say that there's a tech billionaire
who who's concerned about overpopulation
but as we all know our tech billionaires
are concerned about overpopulation yeah
they want fake news
just care about not they just can't not
trying to put us in the metaverse no
i've been diving deep into the metaverse
this last couple weeks that's one thing
i've been doing i i got turned onto this
woman melanie swann by um
allison mcdowell thanks allison who's
very skeptical about blockchain and how
it's basically a big tracking mechanism
this fascist global organization is
going to use blockchain to track people
they want to create a what's called
decentralized autonomous uh
communicative service a d a let's see
what this is called oh i think i'm
coming through loud i hope you guys like
this decentralized autonomous
corporation as a block the blockchain is
a brain they want to upload everyone's
behaviors thoughts and feelings to this
blockchain together to create this uber
mind and then just track it and do what
do what i don't know because a lot of
this code is private elon musk is
building you know brain interface chips
and they're all talking about the
metaverse which is pretty much online
digital heroine from my perspective so i
think it's hilarious
like people will go off about bill gates
but then elon musk will come out and say
no i literally want to put a chip in
your brain yes and then and then nobody
says anything they're like no but he's
cool but elon also attacked crypto
because it was allegedly bad for the
environment you know so so again right
there's he went on snl and attacked it
too exactly so there's a lot of things
that the billionaires are up to that i
think they have way too much control way
too much power way too much influence
and they got there because of government
and now they're using government for
their own personal benefit and the
billionaires are getting super rich
right now from from one year their
wealth increased i think it was 319
billion someone needs to correct me if
i'm wrong one year the top wealth of
nine billionaires increased 319 billion
dollars you saw that photo by the way of
jeff bezos down on his yacht oh yeah
getting serviced by the ladies
by the lady with the lady with the mask
and he's there like glistening in the
sun on his super yacht just like you
know like the you know the uh developing
immunity it will it will not be a tech
this is a and so it will be metaverse
metaverse is how they right
exactly is how they establish elysium
right because the neo-feudalism and then
the elysium tech aspect comes in because
you're distracted you're distracted by
and look palmer lucky like i love you
dude i think you're a good guy and all
but like why did you give oculus to mark
zuckerberg man come on he would have
done it this was a step back
he would have done it regardless he
would have done it regardless but this
this is where it's going and i by the
way i saw zooby just had a just got
booked in the metaverse so he's going to
be playing a a show what um
did he say a website there's a few of
them now there's decent land as one yeah
is is it that
or is it a place it's multiple places
it's like a place
is meaningless what people keep saying
in the metaverse it's like yo there's
been second life there have been apps
for this forever sure and now they're
just calling it a metaverse or the
metaphor they're going to integrate
finances in with it crypto great
branding i got into um yeah mark
zuckerberg's brain it's also the the the
phrase used to describe a nightmare
dystopia but sure i got into this
decentraland bill ottman ceo
this is how they do it man this is how
they're going to do it is you're going
to be hooked up to this and mark
zuckerberg is going to be down at st
bart's and his life's going to be
getting longer and longer and his yachts
are going to be getting bigger and
bigger and leonardo dicaprio's islands
are going to be increasing and he's
going to be bringing more and more
people down there while he talks about
climate change and all this is going to
be going on and you're going to say oh
did you see what's going on on metaverse
you know you're going to be in a pot
eating the bugs you're eight year old is
going to be making money on the
metaverse and going to be completely
dependent on the system it's going to be
terrifying dude totally
from birth plugged in from birth little
kids in the womb might be playing games
with their thoughts the matrix and
digital heroine i think that's more of
an accurate depiction because when
people are hooked on it just like they
are social media you see them in the
grips of what the algorithms make them
and what they're doing to people
especially young people is absolutely
horrible the polls understand that's
inherently anyway you don't need to
explain this to us you just figured it
out what you got
so in star trek what happens is you know
zap from cochrane he discovers warp
technology right as the vulcans were
passing by and they're supposed to first
contact the first kind
um in our reality
the borg was just passing by uh well
that is
we were in the one where they changed
then right because that's actually the
plot of first contact where they go back
in time
and it's the borg that comes but
they make first contact and then you see
for like like a glimpse right where what
the future would look like and it's like
a borg world instead of the earth yeah
toxic gas the atmosphere is diluted so
the humans are just assimilated
immediately yeah yeah the entire planet
no not immediately it's that it shows
you what the 24th century would look
like if the borg had made first contact
rather than the vulcans so for those
that are familiar with this nerd stuff
the borg is a a race of
their people who are assimilated with
technology into a hive mind like
digitally and so they all become
mindless drones basically everything ian
just said it's like a dac a
decentralized autonomous corporation
yeah so what's going to happen
on a blockchain so do you see what alex
jones was saying when he went on that
rant and he was like alien intelligence
has taken us over and i'm sick of it and
like he recently was yelling that
i mean he's been yelling after 20 years
[Laughter]
but artificial intelligence could be
considered alien right because it's
brand new it's defined as a certified
alien yeah and
he might not be wrong especially with
how fast ai has been developing it's
larger consequences of it creating
god-like authority and what putin calls
the new nuclear weapons that will be far
more devastating on humanity and the
country that develops it first will be
the ones controlling the world so
there's a lot to to unpack there but uh
he might he might not be wrong there
let's be real this is what yuval harari
he calls it homodaeus right human gods
human gods and and i think there's
there's a whole metaclip of this where
it's uh it's elon musk on rogan and they
they intersperse it with alex jones on
rogan and you actually hear that they're
saying the same things right they're
talking about the exact same things alex
just does it in a more bombastic way
elon does it in that like softer more
mercurial kind of way but they're
actually describing the exact same
dynamics and forces at play
absolutely it's kind of like um
they say if you keep using old tools to
build the modern system you're just
going to end up with an old system
because you're using old tools so you
use the we're building the tools that we
will use to build the future it's i've
been doing a lot of math in the last
couple weeks and like fibonacci sequence
you take what the past number add it to
the current number to get the future
number so past numbers one the current
number is one the next number's going to
be two everyone forgot and that's what
technology is doing everyone forgot what
yoda taught them we're going to be using
this this time
what's the word
yoda's most important lesson of all
we are luminous beings we are not this
crude matter
hundred percent i think we're the brains
you ever see the picture of the brain
stem connected to the brain with the
brain some of the eyeballs have you ever
seen that picture yes do you look like
an alien that's what we are floating
in china that's just your interface man
in china right now
in china right now go anywhere you need
an app yes and there's the viral video
out of israel where the guy needs the
green pass do you see this one
mcdonald's yeah mcdonald's and then if
you click you don't have one it just
resets yeah it just kicks you out just
you're just this is you're just not this
doesn't exist it's all necessary for
transhumanism
if if if we're going to
uh
in order for transhumanism to exist
people have to step above the human
experience it no longer can be about
carnal pleasures dopamine family
traditional anything
the human race has to be looked at like
lab rats or chickens in a farm or not
even a farm like a laboratory to be
controlled to be mapped out and that's
what these people are doing now they'll
probably end up building an artificial
intelligence that will start guiding
that behavior but ultimately the way i
see it is
you have single celled organisms and
eventually they become multicellular
organisms well single cells go about
their business and do their thing but in
the human body you have highly
specialized cells that that do basically
one thing but they're cells right
i think that's how they view the human
race each individual human is just a
stupid human going about its business
and if we fuse all the humans together
together we can make a multi-organism
system
a higher plane of existence i think that
is part of what they want to do
basically creating a hive mind put
everybody in the metaverse put everybody
in the system have all their brains work
as like decentralized computational
power but
it's going to require everyone to be
it's going to it's going to require
homogenized cultures homogenized
behavior so what do they do
everybody get your green pass everybody
fall in line and those who don't will
it's friction in the system right you're
mentioning friction
you make a system where it's extremely
difficult to exist outside of it and
eventually given a few generations
people will not exist outside of it or
they will be but they'll be irrelevant
yeah there's a very um there's a very
american
ideal that you know i will die for
freedom i will die for the right to make
my own decisions and i will you know
sacrifice myself on the altar of liberty
if if need be and i and i think that
that's that is sort of the american
ethos right um but at the same time
just look at the last two years right
humans comply the by and large the
majority of people will comply and as
the water increases right the boil the
boiling temperature of the water it
increases it increases it increases and
some people will say hey i think this
water is getting hot hey guys i think
these these waters are getting maybe we
shouldn't be in this pot anymore guys i
don't know what we think they so that
guy's crazy he this water isn't getting
hot i feel fine right and yet the water
is getting hotter and hotter and hotter
and then eventually you boil and
meanwhile everybody who jumped out was
called crazy for jumping out in the
first place and i think that's closer to
human nature and i think that we've seen
by and large the distribution pattern of
human behavior has been that look uh
when you come to america when it comes
to liberty when it comes to the
revolution you know people say it was
like less than a third of the american
colonists actually supported the
revolution actually went along with a
little bit more
it's i did a i mean it's hard to yeah
but just really quick before we jump
into that point but there's also a
florida man that don't give a damn that
baits in it and then
alcohol and that's not true excuse me i
was not i'm not i was not bringing
florida man into this there is no need
much love for you no need to bring
forward why do you know why the myth of
florida man is based on sunshine exactly
and they have
we we all know about that but but there
is wait wait break break that down
because that doesn't get said enough
yeah there's uh records release laws
like if you commit a crime in florida
the public has a you know right to know
a lot of states don't do that so you'll
constantly hear stories about florida
man doing something yeah it's just
because they release the influence
because they release the information
other states don't yeah we're all like
if you're bored just look up florida but
in a particular day that being said i
did a lot that being said if you go to
like western florida there's florida man
down there i did a lot of research into
how many people supported the revolution
and there's a famous letter where i
think medman ben franklin wrote a third
support it a third don't care a third
oppose it but that's not true that was
just like a talking point it was just
rhetoric okay the the the best i could
find was that
it was like if i was going to give it a
number because i don't think they gave a
number they said
a a plurality but not a majority around
30 to 40 like 38 to 40 percent supported
independence and then it was like 20
something percent that opposed it and
then the next group was uh completely
neutral but uh it was it was i don't
think it's as cut and dry that most
people didn't care i think that i think
that is true so i think my my math might
be wrong but it was like
it was a mix
the best i could find it's not it's not
easy was that a large portion if not the
majority like the plurality wanted
independence and the next biggest group
was leave me alone i don't care i won't
have nothing to do with this then you
had opposites you had loyalists you had
the tories or whatever they were and
that's and that's why canada exists by
the way yeah quebec said no yeah because
that was originally going to be the 14th
colony right so there were you know the
canadian colonies were still what there
was no separation like there is now it
was just the north american colonies but
a lot of the tories moved up to canada
and said no we're going to fortify this
area this was benedict arnold's original
mission by the way going through the
great lakes to try to take those tory
colonies didn't go so well um he gets
mad that he says he wasn't supported by
washington et cetera as he flips that's
the whole story canadians overlooked for
promotion but they're actually
if you go into this this was the
american invasion of canada yeah no we
did invade uh we we did didn't we we uh
the united states tried taking montreal
burnt and burned toronto well what is
1812 at the time it was no no this is
well yeah that that's at that and then
so at the time it was called york so i
was going to say oh wow and then so the
burning of the white house was kind of
seen as like a response to the burning
of york let's talk about la resistance
from the post-millennial half a million
sign up on getter after joe rogan joins
platform with a simple tweet to see joe
rogan destroyed big tech and tore apart
the chains of political discrimination
holding back millions of patriots okay
that might be a little bit over the top
as we are talking about the power of
silicon valley and the metaverse and
these tech billionaires any opposition
to this be it you know getter or gab or
whatever is a good thing the
post-millennial reports more than half a
million people have joined getter a
pro-free speech social media alternative
the surge in popularity was sparked by
joe rogan i don't think that's true
necessarily um they say it was sparked
by joker and joining the platform
i think it was dr robert malone and
marjory taylor green being banned i
think it was a snowball and well then
malone goes on the on joe rogan's
podcast yeah
i signed up i'm pretty sure i signed up
and a bunch of i saw some people signing
up tim doesn't want to get written out
of the story that's what it is no no i
was not the first person i saw other
people saying they were getting on
getter no i know because you sent me a
message that morning right before joe
rogan said
no i was like i'll back you up on that
you did i said do you know the guys at
getter i want to it's not like i need to
gain control of the account because what
they do is they and a lot of like minds
did this too where they would they would
take like if someone's got a big account
somewhere else they would go and then
reserve the same name for them so that
someone can't come out and camp on your
on your exactly your profile name so i
saw other people posting they were going
to get her i've done this before but
typically i'm like you know when getter
came out i was like i'm not going to
sign up for another one of these things
man i got too many already but then
after listening to joe rogan's podcast
when i heard dr malone say he was going
to be there i was like i'll i'll claim
my account i'll get on there because
if people are going to be using it i
want to hear what they have to say if
they're getting banned and then marjorie
taylor green is on there of course carl
benjamin is on there yeah then i saw joe
rogan sign up and then i was like oh get
it and then everybody after that once
joe wrote this open but it was his
podcast that did it when i heard his
podcast and malone said he was on it
that's when i was like i'm gonna look
this up i'm gonna see what's up so i
think that is what drove it wasn't joe
rogan joining it was joe rogan talking
about we were saying we were saying it
was ghetto miss i mean i had better
engagement and and people know that look
you know i look i don't drink i don't
smoke i don't do drugs
i'm on twitter a little bit though
but i had better engagement on
getter that day or like actually it's
still going on and even till today i've
been having better engagement on getter
than i've been having on twitter and
that's just because there's more people
out there and so there's a lot of people
in the mainstream media who don't
understand what engagement is and they
don't understand how social media works
and i saw some people tweeting out like
oh well getter doesn't have as many
users as twitter so you're diluting your
brand etc etc by going on these things
like no you you don't get how this works
you totally don't get how this works
when the new york times gets like three
retweets yeah they go oh my gosh it's
flood their notifications are flooded
it's crazy when you look at mainstream
celebrities and they get no interactions
there are a few people who work for
these big media companies that i know
and i'm like yo their accounts are so
fake they they get followers um because
they're put on i can always tell dude
suggested user lists
when people sign up for twitter they're
like follow this person they go okay and
then no one cares what the person has to
say well this is the um this is uh the
reuben ratio didn't ruben come up with
that what is that so it was the it was
the reuben ratio where it's the amount
of followers you have versus the amount
of engagement you get ah i've not heard
that yeah so if you have so all and if
you look at like um like an anderson
cooper right like he has a really bad
reuben ratio because he'll have like
three million followers no one engages
20 retweets yeah and then for me i make
some ish post about random garbage and
get like a thousand retweets exactly and
then people in media believe it's real
and then everyone who retweets it's in
on the joke i really love that the funny
thing is
so many uh
i said lol joe biden is so dumb haha got
him or something and then m-e-a-w-w runs
the story like tim poole was slammed i'm
like it was a like isn't it obvious
these people yet like that my tweets are
garbled nonsense it's kind of this weird
dynamic where
they've decided to turn
so you understand like if you're not
someone who's part of the program right
if you're if you're not on team just
look up right
yeah um
you're you're you're a zoo animal right
like you're an exhibit to them it's what
i i remember there was one time where
cernovich and i were just randomly
joking around about how ugly cargo
shorts are and we got written up they're
like
the right wing has launched an attack
campaign on cargo shorts how dare they
and like it's like this thought piece
and they were trying to explain how like
right-wing ideology led to anti and i'm
like guys it was
like it's just we're just messing around
hey hey there's nothing wrong with cargo
shorts is everything wrong i want you
guys real quick i want to say something
important two things completely disagree
uh technically three things twitter does
not drive engagement so this is this was
true back when i worked at vice infusion
they don't like i think
i'm not sure if they did but i'm pretty
sure food engagement on twitter on
twitter but yeah fusion was like we
don't care for our twitter button
because nobody clicks links on twitter
to go out nope so there's a but here's
the important thing on getter check this
out dailymail has signed up for an
account this is big they got 384 000
followers i don't know how many are
actual followers on getter because they
do this thing where they just say you
have followers on twitter for some
reason they they migrate your followers
over yeah and then people claim their
accounts or something yeah and i wish
they would i wish they would it's clever
because it's for a startup but i wish
they would at least at least if you're
as the user you could see the
differentiation right that you could see
hey this is real there's here's what's
important though in their latest posts
from january from yesterday aoc's
ex-communications director says biden is
old
as ish and deeply unpopular it's got 164
reposts like retweets effectively 450
likes 36 replies that is really good
engagement the new york times doesn't
even get that engagement on on twitter
get our engagement's real it's it's
legit people talk and that's what's
important are you engaging with people
but more importantly
they're actually getting played they
probably wouldn't get on twitter yeah
getters
people asking me about this they say
they say why are there so many chinese
accounts on getter and this has come up
a lot and that's one thing where
you know i realized because i've been on
getter for a little bit that people
don't realize this that getter was the
first community that came to it was the
chinese whistleblower community and
these guys i went out and spoke at an
event they held actually on the 4th of
july at the world trade center and my
wife and i got up and we both gave a
speech in mandarin to them it's this
massive organization it's all it's
overseas predominantly overseas chinese
that have fled the regime as well as
some that are inside china still that
are now able to use getter and use other
places to communicate and people don't
realize how many of them there are so i
think something like i was i was
watching an interview
with jason miller and he actually
admitted that like only 30 some percent
of getters user base is u.s
and the rest is overseas and twitter's i
think is is even less than that
twitter's like 15 u.s i just wanted to
ask you what what makes you trust getter
and are there any kind of guarantees
that they won't become the next twitter
and start censoring people because
there's already some rumors that people
are being censored and de-platformed
from there
are there any kind of guarantees that
that that you're reassured by when it
comes together because i i signed up
because i just saw everyone doing it but
i'm of course skeptical i mean i don't
think there's any guarantees on anything
in life was it death and taxes right but
you know i call it and i actually i
think i caught yesterday when you were
talking about this it's your terms of
service right are you being held to are
you are you upholding your terms of
service or are you playing games with
some kind of like amorphous vague
ambiguous community guidelines that
nobody can really make any sense of so
give me at your terms of service okay
i'll read this i'll say i can say this i
can't say that etc same way youtube has
terms of service right they have certain
very clearly delineated things that you
can and can't say okay fine like this is
your play but yours is your playground
i'm going to play by your rules but at
the same time if you're just arbitrarily
censoring people then that's what i'm
going to call out yeah
we read the terms and services they
seemed very legalese and very vague from
our perspective i mean that's how i saw
is there anything particular in there
that that kind of uh you you saw that's
different than the other platforms um
not specifically no okay i'm looking at
the terms right now uh you may not post
i think a lot of that we we read the
gutter terms the other day they have
like profane can't post
hate speeches banned yeah defined speech
is outright banned is it proprietary
explicitly is it proprietary code is it
open source code or proprietary code i
can't find it open source i think it's
it's the term now this is important is
it is it is it criminally defined hate
speech like like the police officers
there's no such thing as criminally
defined you know what i mean well there
is there is another country like who's
who's going to be the one that's what i
mean are they going to be implementing
the laws this is are they going to be
implementing the laws from germany no or
is there going to be someone else who's
going to be making those decisions on
what is hate speech and what is usually
the same who's going to be making those
decisions because this and what what
oversight will there be with rumble
though this is the issue because rumble
is canadian and in canada they do have
hate speech laws it comes down to the
state that the company is incorporated
in you got to follow those state laws if
you're going to go by and getter is
incorporated but they don't know but
then rumble is moving to florida right
they're moving their headquarters my
question is
will their move to florida then change
their terms of service it'll change how
they define what's legal in a sense
because even though there's totally
operating the terms are written so they
can stay on the play store in the app
store well yeah obviously you don't have
to enforce them ever that's true
yeah uh but they check that stuff
well they make excuses i mean twitter is
loaded with adult content and they don't
care about that
you know it's like hasn't that always
been part of twitter though no i'm
pretty sure it's not allowed i think
it's it's quote unquote not allowed but
they allow it like every social network
they can ban you at any time for any
reason dorsey when dorsey was ceo like
he was always very public that they
allowed porn i don't know if that's true
you want to pull that up see if you
think twitter twitter did use porn i'm
pretty sure i think twitter i'm sure
it's not allowed i think twitter has
always said that we allow this because
the app store doesn't allow that really
the app store will ban you if you allow
adult content and yet yet another yeah
and this goes back to luke's theory of
the tech overlords have one set of rules
no no if you type twitter porn into
search there's a lot of twitter porn
accounts coming up i'm not okay well
that's not what we're
focused on we're staying focused okay we
got a job you want to know is porn on
twitter was that the question is it
banned no no no
i think we all generally argue that it
is on twitter yes it is oh it's on
twitter the question is is it uh against
is it a loud or is it against the terms
you know is it against the terms of
certain consensual nudity policy well
that's that's like revenge important
yeah central nudity they're okay with
why doesn't twitter block porn
i think the idea was there you go to
twitter terms of service it's it will
state under this that it it
differentiates between uh consensually
produced
you may vote you may not post media that
are successfully gory or share violent
or adult content within live video or in
profile or header images media depicting
sexual violence and or assault is also
not permitted so does that mean porn is
banned that sounds like you could click
no it's just saying it's just saying
that it can't be in your your profile or
your header right but it can be in your
actual feed
no it doesn't even say anything about
that
i don't know
uh you can't advert
it does not actually
look up the revenge porn policy because
well that's obvious no but i believe
it's mentioned in there
that was that was it
yeah what is not a violation of the
policy look oh i see pornography and
other forms of consensus are allowed on
twitter they are all on twitter all
right well then how are they allowed in
the app store yeah that's a good
question and that's something that we
battle with that minds in the early days
like how do you they just know people
it's because the technology because
they're out there the oligarchs they're
right there in the club man the friends
of the friends you're not interesting
interesting
ultimately i think all these sites
should be allowed to have whatever terms
they want expect to get banned on any of
them if it's not your platform that's
one way to go about it i don't trust any
of this stuff especially if the code's
private let's talk let's talk about uh
some cultural issue here
and it's going to be a hard side we read
the story from the independent i think
it's it's important to talk about
youtuber ethan klein calls joe rogan a
piece of ish for vaccine misinformation
rogan's fan hit back after klein calls
out how podcasters logic makes no sense
i appreciate you bringing back ish by
the way well luke did actually i looked
it up it was one of my favorite words
i can't say much here it's deserve it's
deserves my vocabulary has been cut in
like 25 of it has been cut so so ethan
klein a host of h3 he's still working on
english
hit out at podcaster joe rogan saying
joe rogan who lives on elk meat egg yolk
and human growth hormone with lungs full
of tar thinks he's healthier than
everyone
this mf or shab that when he got coveted
he threw the kitchen sink at it if
you're so healthy just write it out like
you say a man should do this cause so
much vaccine hesitancy and
misinformation and he doesn't even have
the balls to stand by the issue preaches
now he's on his show talking about how
fat people should just die of covet due
to such an effing piece of s
um
is i mean i i wait does i have a
legitimate question that's not a dig is
ethan klein saying this because he's an
unhealthy overweight individual yes
and so like it was like when joe rogan
was talking about being overweight and
unhealthy was bad for you
i think people yeah people take it
personally so if you understand if you
understand um
uh
sociosexual hierarchy right this is
typical gamma male rage against an alpha
male right this is the basic idea of you
know someone who's kind of at the bottom
of the food chain in in terms of
preference
lashing out at someone who is higher up
on the food chain from them and it's
it's very simple you see this a lot
with youtubers but not just youtubers in
general that's just they're more
ubiquitous these days um you see it
everywhere you see it in real life you
see it in you know
office hierarchy see it in high schools
colleges it's political leadership
that's when it's scary to an extent well
political leadership is a little bit
different though because political
leadership isn't
is not
conducted because just because of
someone's um you know health and prowess
and and accomplishment right there's all
these like byzantine rules and ways i
mean look at you know we've got like the
peter principal presidency right now joe
biden was not picked because he's our
most competent leader right
that's not exactly how he got there so
for ethan klein to lash out it's totally
in line if you understand sociosexual
hierarchy that being said my question is
he says lungs full of tar is is jarwick
and a smoker i didn't i mean yeah right
yeah
does he i don't think
cigars pops on oh that's right that's
right i'm pretty sure he does smoke but
does he inhale
i don't know you don't have really
you're not supposed to enhance obviously
so how would your lungs be filled with
tar then i don't i don't know but we
should also point out that this is some
of the stupidest advice given out by
ethan klein that absolutely makes no
sense you're telling joe rogan not to
take medicine that a doctor is telling
him to take this is the paradox of what
he said uh ethan klein is not a medical
doctor no one here is a medical doctor
no we we all have our opinions look is a
medical doctor hell
no but ethan klein to be like joe rogan
shouldn't give medical advice you should
you should not listen to an image and
listen to them it's like bro you
shouldn't be giving medical advice oh
yeah he should be hit by youtube in
terms of services twitter look look up
what the medical background of the ceo
of pfizer is what is it
just a veterinarian boom oh he's a
veterinarian he's a veterinarian
and a salesman a very good one
interesting joe is uh
he's a healthy guy yeah that's just i
mean
i saw a uh instagram video of him doing
a front kick couple years ago he looks
like he was 42 years old yeah he's great
he exercises all the time now there i
mean you can you can certainly talk
about you know your opinions on diet and
whether or not you know eating so much
red meat or whatever is good or bad but
for ethan klein it's good too
paradoxically it's it's actually a bit
ironic i suppose of him to be like joe
rogan's an idiot for for saying these
things when he's quite literally a
podcaster saying the exact same things
in the other direction it's the same
problem
like you should not be you know you know
what a lot of people have pointed out
the goal of what he said was to generate
press and it worked here we are talking
about him obviously the media is writing
about um
you know congratulations explain to me
what's wrong exactly with egg elk meat
egg yolks and hgh okay i don't know oh i
don't know i i like that i can tell i
was using that as as an insult
he like wrapped he's saying he's not two
nascent ones in with like a more
controversial one and it's supposedly
again it's like it's like bro you're on
the side of of gmos you're on this like
you would be on the side of the sackler
family early on in the oxycontin debate
when it comes to this how dare you be
against the sacklers i don't i don't
think he tweeted for attention i think
it's it's like the people tweet because
people tweet oh let's get them about
rage dude no 100 well sure sure he was
not thinking about any of that stuff
he's an unhealthy guy who clearly does
not eat right or exercise joe said
that's a huge comorbidity and ethan got
upset about it and said who are you to
criticize me when you know you won't
take the vaccine or whatever explain to
me the pathology right and i've still
been trying to actually find find this
one and if anyone's in the chat who has
this i've been i because i always try to
examine the various like there's you
know dr mullen talked about mass
formation psychosis but there's also
like narrow formation psychosis there's
all these different little bands of
pathologies around in our society today
and this uh post-industrial society that
we have and so
the the interesting one that i found is
like show me a guy who looks like ethan
klein who's like triple vaxxed you know
giga vaxxer who's eaten ubereats and
doordash all the time
and yet will scream their head off about
you being unvaxed as a threat to their
health
what is the pathology there of someone
who clearly has not done taken one step
to change their personal behavior
demand that you change yours the cdc has
said around 30 of covet hospitalizations
are in the obese yes cnn just came out
with a report this is what rogan was
commenting on that obesity is a huge
contributing factor to hospitalizations
and even death
i don't understand why ethan should be
mad about that he's he's saying now he's
now he's on a show talking about how
fast people should just die of code yeah
i'm pretty sure joe rogan didn't say
that if joe rogan said that that clip
would be er aware right right joe
probably was like you got to get healthy
man you know start eating better we want
to talk about national exercise you know
mandatory exercise 10 minutes
mandatory calisthenics all right let's
go let's go i see luke's smiling i i
wouldn't do it just because the
government made me do it even though i'm
exercising right now that's what i'm
thinking about like poland does not
comply never i think that ethan wants in
on the conversation i feel like he
missed the boat into the intellectual
dark web because he's a smart enough guy
but his joking kind of idiocy persona
thing is keeping him out of the club and
he's angry about it like dude i don't
even know if the idw is like the idw is
a thing for people to like attack but it
hasn't actually been a thing for years
yeah just the idea of like a smart a
group of really intelligent podcasting
people that are communicating and have
kind of a community ethan kind of i
think he wants in on that however
speaking of which i believe the both
weinstein brothers signed up for getter
oh did they i belie yeah both both i
mean the big the big story would be
daily mail when when oh yeah when
services start signing up yes it's no
longer just people high-fiving each
other you can actually use the service
because they've because they've realized
though that from a corporate perspective
that hey we can make money off of this
all right and that's as simple as that
and i think i think once you've crossed
that bridge not now you're the dick we
we got to get our crew to set up that uh
set up that account so we'll we'll we'll
hit up the guys um we're actually uh we
normally don't announce guests in
advance so i won't give any specific
dates but we're going to have the getter
guys on the show nice or get our guy
yeah when i'm supposed today yeah luke
to talk about this keep your questions
ready for those guys man in real time
start working on advertising yeah i
don't know i don't like i don't i don't
work for those guys or anything i just i
like it um i think ian will get a lot of
traffic there yeah with your experience
with mine yeah just nail them if you can
start ringing in an advertising program
and get these people paid man this
thing's going to take off
but i want you to open source your code
and then we'll federate that's the big
the big move is is um
i think if we start putting all the
articles we write at timcast.com on
getter then that's going to be huge for
us we're going to see way more traction
because people are going to be using it
but it gives you a reason to be on
getter and then you can track you know
you can compare
i think engagement will be massive i
think if i'm telling you i've seen it
when i post to twitter etc my various
platforms getter is huge but if it's way
better if they're able to to do that but
also implement transparency and
accountability for a lot of their
decisions that would put them over the
top because people will now know that
there's some some kind of accountability
some kind of responsibility on the
individuals and you will clearly know
what you can and cannot say big tech now
kind of works in this mysterious way
where they let other people like ethan
klein give medical advice and other
people like congressmen and medical
doctors and key innovators of the mrna
vaccine technology be censored on that
platform for what i think this is wrong
somewhat zap dr malone that's cool
though
phd scientist robert malone banned from
twitter ethan klein dude on youtube not
no no and i'll even go this far to say
tim poole dude on youtube not i post so
much random crackbot insanity on twitter
and i'm like i don't even know how i
still have an account but they banned
scientists and sitting members of
congress that's yeah the system is
broken and and again what um
ethan klein is criticizing here is is a
cocktail that according to aaron rodgers
who also came out and said that he reads
ann rand today by the way uh just
another shout out here but but most
importantly what i wanted to mention
here that we can avoid some better
literature
jack don't get me started here
most importantly what aaron rodgers also
said is that nfl teams are secretly
using the joe rogan kitchen sink
cocktail so this is something that ethan
klein is is criticizing that of course
has helped a lot of people it helped
dana white it helped aaron rodgers it
helps a lot of professional football
players according to aaron rodgers
within the nfl so so
why are you criticizing this how is this
your attack point here i don't i don't i
don't care about aaron rodgers opinion i
guess he got the jersey behind him i
don't care about the nfl's opinion i
care about the fact that they were
prescribed something from a doctor
so there when when the memes go out and
they say like oh my doctor doesn't know
anything about this my response is
always dude if you hired a carpenter who
couldn't tell you what a tool was or
what what kind of wood you were using
you wouldn't hire that person if these
it's crazy to me that this position of
you mentioned this earlier ethan klein
is rogan should not have listened to his
doctor that's insane no you should
listen to a trusted medical professional
you get second opinion but what is the
response joe should have been like ethan
klein is right doc i'm not gonna listen
to you i'm gonna listen to ethan klein
imagine imagine joe rogan walking up to
his anybody walking up to their doctor
with ethan klein's tweet printed out and
saying i'm sorry sir but ethan klein
this paragon of health virtue has told
me and don lemon and don lemon right
uh i actually um whatever tell you my
the story when i met don lemon
no yeah so i um i was at when i was
still at one america news
we uh bought a table at the white house
correspondents association
uh believe it was 2018. yeah so right
after i started so i'm there this was
the one where they made fun of sarah
sanders for her um her eye shadow do you
remember that and that became a whole
thing and she was like on stage they had
this like horrible comedian so
in between that kathy griffin was there
i was sitting next to right the table
right next to me by the way was david
hogg funny enough so and our chairs were
like almost like directly next to each
other it's funny um
and he was kind of quiet and
so
in between the different you know
speeches everybody would run to the
bathroom and so you know all the dudes
and you're all in tuxedos and you're
waiting in line it's a men's room but
like everybody's like kind of like a you
know like like you recognize everybody
in line even if you don't know them kind
of situation and then all of a sudden
don lemon just walks up and he goes
excuse me excuse me excuse me i'm done
loving and just pushes it seriously dead
serious ahead of everybody who's in line
every correspondent excuse me excuse me
i'm downloading excuse me actually
saying that excuse me and then just
walks right in front of the whole line
he should have been like you shouldn't
use me and he wasn't
not even making eye contact with anybody
just like
uh i'm ahead and you all know people let
him cut everything let's let's make a
passage that none of us ever would come
like that you guys when i when i was
just it wasn't like he was like a host
or part of the show or anything like
that i say this all the time to people
if you are in line anywhere and cut
people they will do nothing
people do not want confrontation you can
it's always been the craziest thing that
people waiting lines i'm kind of the guy
that'll say something
because you're disconcerting all these
people
yeah when i was in russia there was no
line although i did i did well in russia
the line is your elbow right so in china
from a mad dash and it's like a royal
rumble when you're kind of getting those
little old ladies when you're trying to
get on the subway if like i'm telling
you they've got low center of gravity
and i'm telling you they would come
right out for me they're thick and they
would take they get in there yeah they
would take their bags and just bam i was
like
i'm dead serious i was at the airport in
moscow when i was traveling i was going
from uk to moscow to ukraine and in the
west when they were like now barney
group one group one walks over and they
get and now barney and group two and
then two gets up
in russia they were like now boarding
group one and every single person rushed
full speed it was a massive people's
shoulder to shoulder pushing each other
out of the way and i was like all right
here we go and then i just i'm i'm used
to being in there
and if you don't do that by the way
you're not getting on the plane that's
right or you're getting on last you're
not gonna worry or you might yeah you
might get on last you won't get overhead
space and so i was like all right if
this is the game we're playing and i
just shoved through everybody and then
boarded like right away i was like okay
yeah people don't understand that the
whole concept of like waiting in line
and waiting your turn that is totally a
western thing and it's a very american
thing outside the country does it do not
exist speaking of western things we have
the story that uh jack mentioned to us
earlier that it's huge this is my
hometown my hometown the eastern
district of pennsylvania yeah third
former glaxosmithkline scientist pleads
guilty to stealing trade secrets to
benefit chinese pharma company whoa whoa
jack what's going on
you've got a situation here so
glaxosmithkline which has a massive
facility in uh southeastern pennsylvania
throughout upper marion this is king of
prussia area people don't or valley
forge uh people i'm sure no valley forge
as well as malvern pennsylvania one of
the richer areas of um all of
pennsylvania
has a bunch of facilities down there
there were chinese scientists who were
basically working for this company while
also some of them working some of them
subcontract contracting with gsk which
is a british pharma company by the way
that's um that has facilities in the
united states were essentially for years
stealing secrets proprietary research
from glaxosmithkline their research that
that upper millerian facility for galaxo
is a research and development center for
them they were stealing proprietary
secrets sending it back to china and
believe it or not believe it or not and
let the theorizing uh fly because in
2015 the specific thing that they were
stealing secrets on was monocolonal
antibodies no this is coming directly
from and we're just reading the doj
press release on this do they mention
that in the press release monoclonals
that's where i got it from that's the
only thing i've seen on it so far really
it's like yeah a couple paragraphs down
i'm looking it up do you know when they
were invented look at that look at that
in january 2015 lucy she sent john may
that he pronounced it a gsk document
which contained confidential and trade
secret data and information the document
provided a summary of gsk research into
monoclonal antibodies at that time in
the body of the email lucy she wrote you
need to understand it very well it will
help you in your future business what
reno pharma what
they're powerful
i'll put that up sinister afoot
apparently they've been around since
1975 doing a little research on the
monoclonal antibody treatment process
monoclonal antibodies have been around
for a long time there's a bunch of
different kinds
they use for a bunch it's really a
fascinating process i think that they
start to generate some sort of cells in
the mouse and then they take those out
and put them inside of a guinea pig and
then that's where they produce the
antibodies isn't it related to stem
cells and stem cells
i don't know much more about it okay i
was listening to peter mccullough
talking about it on rogan's podcast
fascinating stuff go watch it if you
haven't seen it yet
and that treatment now is also being
denied to a lot of people because of the
way that they were born especially in
places like new york where the governor
has ruled that if you know you're born a
particular way you can't even get some
of these therapies so it has to be
equitable
right absolutely which is absolutely
crazy that we have a health policy run
like this but again the united states is
already very dependent on on china for a
lot of our medical equipment for a lot
of our drugs that are imported here and
the fact that china is still gaming the
market this way china has also tried to
effectively take the tests that a lot of
people take through kovid so they could
also dna harvest according to the fbi
the general public of the united states
so they could game the big pharma market
i think china sees big pharma as a big
threat as a big institution and they're
trying to counter and become them in
many instances i think this is an
example of one of those but there's many
instances
so to break that down right and i and
gsk by the way also has huge facilities
right outside of shanghai i've been
there um when i was with the american
chamber and i was working with um
international business in shanghai so
what they but the difference is the rn
so you know how like what does it say on
the back of like an apple or an apple
iphone it says you know designed in
california right usually says that even
though of course california's in the
united states but that's another story
should say design in the usa but we know
why they don't do that so the r d is
typically done in the united states or
somewhere in the west but the precursors
and the actual manufacturing that's
what's being done in china now so the
chinese government the ccp understands
that as long as you cut the proprietary
information out you're only giving us
the stuff that's down the chain we don't
understand how you you know you put it
all all together we don't understand the
research side of it and so the game for
these companies is to keep you know it's
it's kind of like um you know kfc keeps
their you know their recipe a secret so
you can tell what the ingredients are
but you don't know it all exactly the
way it's done and so the idea is for
china if they can then go
and steal all the way you put it
together the same way you were just
talking about the source code you get
the source code now you can cut them out
now you can do it yourself
so you think the chinese spies the
aspiring was stealing the source code of
how to produce the antibodies out of
philadelphia that's 100 percent okay i
think jack is saying that you're a
chinese buy-in you're constantly trying
to free the code by the way online to
everyone because i'm not
a chinese spy truck
i'm a huge fan of uh of the chinese and
i'm i'm sad to see the way that this the
ccp has hijacked the system
it's true well you know ai has been um
again with their development in that
field is also very eye-opening but but
when it comes to intellectual property
they also have stolen a lot and have
been able to so you leave this is how
you leap frog this is how you leap frog
all that stuff like in in shanghai for
example uh right life that's why i
always go back to it that you know they
never so remember when when the united
states
went through a process with phones you
know you go from edison you go from you
know the original it's sort of like a
dial and then you go to the switchboard
and then you go to rotary phones and
then eventually you get you get fiber
optic and cellular right so you don't
need phone lines when you build a new
house anymore because nobody wants it
you might need something for internet
but for you're not building you're not
wiring the house anymore well shanghai
never had to go through that process
they don't have wires all over the place
so they just leapfrogged it it's the
same because they were able to get the
technology from us right they learned it
from us so it's the exact same process
they're leapfrogging and then at the
same time they've got the money and the
manpower to be able to once they get
that process once they get the source
code once they get the technology then
they can cut us out then eventually
think of this right they they cut us out
on that end they already have all the
precursors
now we have to go to them
china's the future here's a question if
you could get say there was a treatment
like monoclonal antibodies and it turned
out it was amazing but there was
american pharma companies trying to
profit off of other stuff but you could
get the colonel antibodies super cheap
from the ccp
would you do it or would you boycott the
ccp but ian we already are that's crazy
that's that's that's that's what luke's
saying is that we all all of this stuff
already comes through this ecb like this
isn't some new thing
right it's it's that our companies our
wall street firms our silicon valley
firms have all made deals with the ccp
to get their manufacturing to get their
slave labor elon musk just opened a
tesla facility in xinjiang right in
xinjiang china elon musk who won his
weibo page praises the ccp for their 100
years of glory and like i get what he
does right he goes to the us and he says
what he wants what they want to hear he
goes to europe he goes to china like
like it's not hard to figure that out um
but understand what's going on here
right there's there's that there's the
higher level there's the overworld and
then there's the stuff that we can see
down here
i uh it's all a big joke
i want to double check you guys know ben
gertzel you familiar with his room he's
like the preeminent uh artificial
intelligence scientist on earth i've
i've i've heard the name yeah he's in
china let me double check this andreas
told me what about china why would he be
in china
that's my question because he wants to
be on the court well there's also no uh
kind of regulations and the government
allows private enterprise which they
essentially control in many aspects to
do whatever they want this is why dr
fauci allowed dangerous you know gain of
function research to be done in china
and not in the united states because he
couldn't do it in the united states
because of all the rules and regulations
he could have done it with china if he
gave china the source code and the
information of what they were working on
at this point the conspiracy theorists
have been right so often i'm ready to
just be like alex you know just just
give me the list and we'll just we'll
just they're not conspiracy theorists
they're spoiler alerts
i like the meme where it's like 20 20 or
it's like 20 20 conspiracy theorists
2021 conspiracy analyst and it's like a
picture of the first guy is like just
like writing regular clothes second
one's wearing a suit you saw somebody
made a meme already going back to ethan
klein of that they put uh oh yeah
health expert ethan klein conspiracy
theorist joe joe rogan's all right he's
like all right it's all like morbidly
obese and just like with the bc i hooked
up to his oculus no but this is
you know this is like this was that he
was wearing the oculus he's not but
he should be if i were if i were making
the meme he would because that would
just take it to the next level
absolutely i mean again this is what
they want they want you to say oh who's
playing in metaverse tonight who's doing
that and then you get distracted by that
meanwhile you you're missing the entire
like talk about
um you know the way they they want you
worried about the wage gap right between
the quote unquote which gap between men
and women so you're not talking about
the wage gap that luke is talking about
between the oligarchs and everybody else
right so they may they pit you against
each other so against left and right
male female
you know ethnic different you know
racial stuff that they want to get you
all divided on so that you're not
looking at against the up down axis at
all it's been that way uh
forever for all of human history
literally right and this and this big
split with like crt happened a big
fissure moment was occupied wall street
there's that famous cartoon where it's
all the people protesting saying we're
the 99 and then the rich guy's in the
room and he says introduce them to
identity politics
i so and we might get into this later
you know but i told lydia it was i was
gonna bring it up i said and i have a
jump off point so i'm going with it
we at human events we found a tumbler
post
by 12 clara who is a universe who's a
user there who basically admitted
that glee the tv show was the plague
ship for wokeness into the american
mainstream what the tv show plague ship
was the plague ship
this user now 12 clara was one of like
the leaders of the glee online fandom on
tumblr this post she wrote which is
basically like an epitaph to all of that
is admit just admitting all of this
where do you guys think the word
problematic came from where do you guys
think that the idea of um the
representation anger you know do we have
do we have a character who fits this
demographic that demographic do you have
a character who is this who's that right
that all comes sorry from from glee and
from the original glee fandom and then
the wars because people get mad about it
arise from this idea of people becoming
not just sympathetic for the characters
but actually empathetic by actually
viewing the television character as a
mirror image of themselves where that
where it's not only identity politics
from the sense of racial and gender but
identity politics from the idea of i
identify with a tv character because and
don't get me wrong i love the work that
chris rofo and james lindsey have done
tracking this stuff academically but
people have not tracked the pop culture
history of wokeness to explain why it
came about and when if you look at the
history of glee and occupy wall street
that sort of you know middle 2010s
milieu people don't realize social media
that show
hitting social media pre-netflix right
all of these things hitting at the same
time just launched all of this stuff
into the strategy but i i think social
media is the biggest driver of all of it
um i i think glee played a role in pop
culture but i think
it's part uh when did glee come out do
you know what year starts 2009 yeah and
then it got big by in 2011 is when it
got big the exact beginning
i still think it's social media no it's
but that's what i'm saying though it's
the combination of social media with
these tv shows that are introducing
people it's the first time it's not
academia uh i think i know and i agree
with you on that yeah peter pagosian and
i have debated this stuff
may have originated there in some sense
but these guys on that nobody on tumblr
is you know going and reading these
academics
it's that when you at universities
there's a bunch of different ideologies
correct there's critical race theory
there used to be there used to be but uh
this is the one ideology you know
critical race theory that comes out and
expands and it's because
intersectionality was uh social media
was a prime vector for stuffing keywords
and articles so you can say you know
trans women of color being experiencing
police brutality is the epitome of black
lives matter and you've hit every single
keyword you get more views and thus
critical race theory starts becoming
more more prominent
there you go so yeah i know i don't see
this i don't see this as necessarily
being
uh
in in conjunction with that or or in
contrast to that what i'm saying is
this is you've got to read this post
right it's it's just amazing what she
lays out where she's on twitter or
something this oh we have the whole
thing everywhere right um lydia i think
i say
where the post millennial did yeah post
millennial did so our version is like
super long and gets into like a ton of
different things they went in and did
basically a summary where we just post
her tumblr do you know when they posted
it in 2017. i like how you know
millennial posted that no personally i
posted it today oh okay and then
what it's called it is i think you just
work if you look up glee it'll probably
come up i like that you mentioned the
the psychosis that can come from
identifying with the tv character which
isn't a real person exactly and this is
where which game of thrones character
are you which glee character are you
exactly these people like so the
popularity of those shows plus
intersectionality hitting identity
politics and social media at the same
time you put this was a tv show by the
way that was getting
30 million people in ratings at one
point right this is a massive
massive cultural here's a story from
postmodern entertainment consultant
admits glee sparked the woke movement
within the us oh did i mention that by
the way the tumblr user 12 clara it did
an interview with salon where she kind
of like quasi-outed herself in terms of
real name and said oh by the way my real
name is aaron what do you do now i work
as a hollywood entertainment consultant
wow nice of course of course they all
come from tupler
so were they consulted at the time
no no no so when they were on tumblr and
involved in like the toxic glee fandom
no um right there the gleam fandom is
not history it's blood i still see it
all over this website the vague post the
deactivated urls where do you think the
word problematic became popular where do
you think the representational anger
glee was the hungry gaping void that
consumed us all
it's it said watch us and watch us and
find yourself there's something from
everyone and there's characters lesbian
characters gay characters bisexual
etcetera etcetera etcetera it goes on
and going on and said this is your only
outlet for body positivity we are all
oppressed by something but we are
different and we are outcast and we are
you everyone's oppressed so long as you
agree with them exactly if you challenge
it and say an individual can be strong
they say no because i think it's really
simple well
telling an individual
telling an individual they're strong
breaks their collectivism
telling an individual they're weak and
oppressed means you have to be a part of
the collective otherwise you'll be
victimized well and this is amazing
because it's like the show portrays all
the protagonists of the show and we do
mention of course the glee curse and we
get into that as well a little bit
but it portrays all of the main
characters as victimized and oppressed
and all of this when you've got
the uh captain of the football team the
captain of the cheerleading squad you
know these people they're they're all
gorgeous they're great singers they're
putting on like somehow they're able to
do broadway level productions at like
some random high school in ohio
and
they seem to be quite popular across
stage and screen in in universe right in
the show and yet they're told that they
are victimized and oppressed and then
they wear that as the branch of honor
this i'm telling you that audience that
came up watching this show and then the
other shows that spun off of it this was
one of the biggest plague ships of
wokeness into the mainstream
ship the plague ship
yeah like i'm not saying this is like
and people were you know we're trying to
flame the comments you know when i
posted on twitter today they said well
well you know possibly this isn't the
very first place that we saw political
correctness this isn't wasn't like guys
i'm not saying that i'm saying this was
one of the biggest vectors but because
the later seasons of it sucked and
because of the glee curse which and you
know horrific things the leakers the
fact that three of the main characters
are now the three of the main actors are
now deceased whoa
what what
yeah no seriously so corey monteith dies
first he he was the original main
character right and what about the show
uh he od's 2013. oh wow during the
show's course so he he od
and this was the captain of the football
team character uh who od's then
you know what happened to mark salling
right no
i don't watch glee i don't know these
people are uh i know the huge story
though um so i think it was while the
show was wrapping up he gets busted for
child porn
and this was sort of like the bad guy so
he was sort of like the the foil for the
main football player he was like you
know the tight end or something on the
team but he was like the bad boy who
cheated on the cheerleader with you know
with him and everything
and he gets busted for child porn uh
gets arrested later hangs himself wow
yeah and then um the other cheerleader
not the captain but santana
and this this is a legitimate tragedy
this is just uh just a real tragedy it's
just last year she drowned in in a lake
outside of los angeles while trying to
save her four-year-old son their
boat had capsized or something
and she she gets her son back in
they find the sun
later on alone
and have no idea where the mother is
they find her body you know later on you
know and that's part of that's brutal
man
but you know just this crazy curse they
call it like the glee curse
do you think that it was um so what i'm
saying my my contention is that and as
horrific as all those things are
my contention is the fact that glee
isn't in the discourse as much anymore
is because people talk about it in terms
of this curse but they also
totally overlook the fact that it was
the plague ship that introduced a lot of
wokeness to a huge broad swath
particularly of millennials who are
watching this thing because remember we
know they weren't working in 2009 right
you know nobody's got jobs everybody's
you know maybe going into more debt
while they're working on their masters
and they're they're starting to sign up
to twitter they're starting to sign up
to tumblr and what are they talking
about they're talking about glee
and they would have been 10 and 12 years
old now they're 23.
do you think that it was intentionally
produced that way to do that or just
more like this is how we these people
happen to feel like victims and they
wrote a show about so we we researched
this and then i didn't write the piece
but i did edit it and one thing that we
do track is that when the show was
originally written it was actually kind
of like a parody right sort of a parody
of like high school musical and it was
satirical it was actually kind of
tongue-in-cheek and it was meant to be
self-aware and it was the fandom that
turned it into that so when the fandom
became so incredibly tribal about i
demand that my character that i identify
with go through these you know aspects
or the whole idea of if you know
anything about fan culture uh shipping
right do you guys know shipping yeah
what is it oh man so okay
what is shipping so shipping is
basically where you like create this
mindset where these people that you see
in the show are in a relationship oh
right it's like a fan right or so you
want the characters to be in
relationship but then in some aspects of
some fandoms it gets so bad that you
actually start making up these like
conspiracies that the actors themselves
are also secretly in a relationship they
did this by the way with the star wars
movies the disney star wars movies they
called themselves reylo's
right
and dead serious and
the reylos all believed that adam driver
and um what's the girl's name daisy
daisy ripley um
had were in a secret relationship they
started harassing adam driver's actual
wife in real life
because
again the parasocial relationship went
beyond right so you've got an empathetic
media mass psychosis you know formation
going on where they need they have an
insatiable urge for their false reality
or what we might call it a metaverse
reality to come in and actually take the
form in the real world to the point
where the fact that adam driver is
actually married to someone separate and
that he's a real person who's you know
i'm sure he's in love with his wife
that's why he married her um that she
needs to be removed from the story
because that does not satisfy the
beliefs of the reylos dude what are
humans i know
i know right
and it's and it's amazing and it's wild
and unfortunately it's all true and the
fact that people overlook this influence
the toxic influence and you could look
at other shows like so
i the reason that i'm kind of halfway
into this stuff is because i originally
started my twitter account and blog in
2012 to make fun of the game of thrones
tv show and so i sort of came up online
through that and then eventually got
into making fun of politics and here i
am um and so
but i remember that the game of thrones
online fandom was just as bad but it
wasn't as big as glee was at the time
but it was it was ridiculous and i
remember like i got kicked out of the
the dc game of thrones book club because
you know i i i remember saying i thought
it was funny that people were pirating
all the episodes and so hbo wasn't
getting any of the money and these
people lost their minds they completely
lost their mind i got banned from the
game of thrones reddit i got banned from
all these different things
because i didn't have these types of
like
false empathetic media relationships
whereas other people were were literally
i they could not separate themselves
from that false reality and i think by
the way the most ubiquitous one of these
of all um the reason i don't mention it
in terms of wokeness is because it's not
particularly woke though is harry potter
right and and there is a reason that
every aging childless millennial
will always use harry potter as their
reference their frame of reference for
literally everything there was this
creepy post on reddit where this uh
teenage girl was like my parents named
me after a harry potter character my
brother after a star wars character
they're obsessed with it we hate it we
hate all of it we get made fun of
millennials man how about we do this how
about we go to super chat i'm sorry i'm
sorry all right hundred of millennials
i'm i'm sorry smash that like button
subscribe except for my children of
course subscribe to the channel smash
that like button go to tim catcher
become a member and we're gonna have a
members only segment coming up for you
guys at around 11 or so p.m it's again
at timcast.com become a member as a
member you're helping support our fierce
and independent journalism and you're
helping support this show but don't
forget to uh like the like smash that's
what i wrote in the pinned comment
somebody i got messages from people
because the other day i put smash the
smash like and i actually got a bunch of
emails they were like hey just wanna let
you know you made a mistake and i was
like
that's
intentional all right let's see we got
here
seth boos says tim i know it's early but
since you have poso you asked when the
last time a new christmas song was
written sabaton wrote christmas truce
check it out christmas truce is
excellent i love that song really i've
never heard it so it's it's well you you
know so sabaton all these always not
always but they do now um they write
metal power metal songs about actual
military history and actual battles
and
so but in christmas truce of course
that's not a battle that was the
armistice that was held on christmas day
between the french and the german
soldiers and they played a game of
soccer across the trenches
yes yes yes yeah cool story
alex tobias says hey tim i'm a video
game i'm a video game artist i'm going
to be fired soon for not getting the
procedure i sent an email to jobs in
april but no reply happy to send another
one if you'd like hi post i'm a big fan
um let me write down your name because
actually i think we need a video game
artist sentence in the
i
ufo
write down your name send an email to
spin the ufo at gmail.com right yeah
what's his name alex tamayo perfect i'll
look for that and then um you know we'll
take a look at your samples and we do
need uh a video mr i believe i believe
we do we have we have a couple projects
in the works and so we could definitely
use that assistance
dragon audiobook says my name is marco i
make audiobooks like founders keep an
epic fantasy fiction story with dragons
magic and adventure
oh that's very cool that's awesome
all right let's see where we are at
some people saying um welcome back ian
hi everyone waffle sensei ian welcome
back you look good bro nice shave we
love you thanks dude yeah what were you
doing where were you i went to ohio for
about 10 days spent some time with
family and friends that was incredible i
went to washington state with a friend
of mine i micro dosed on some mushrooms
and saw the world clearly it was
absolutely wonderful and um
spent a lot of time watching
fractal geometric patterns like the 64
tetrahedron the flower of life highly
recommend looking into it thanks for
asking tim all right uh ghost crusader
says ian is correct at the end of the
langoliers they run down the terminal
holding hands and jump in the air to a
freeze frame lock it in yo i didn't i
didn't realize stephen king did the um
the um
the miniatures no no no no did the the
the what you call it the um
16 candles who did 16 candles john news
john hughes yeah the john who's ending
oh yeah it's really funny well the 80's
unused yeah right later johnny just got
away from that stuff
there's in in ready player two there's a
whole john hughes planet inside the uh
the oasis
you know i would love to it's some day
in the future let's let's have a
psychedelic expert on because my
experience with mushrooms i mean graham
hancock graham hancock oh we'll do it
we'll do that get graham the largest
organism in the world is that mycelial
net under earth it's fascinating
creature mckenna would also be good i
interviewed him because
the grim truth says i feel about ian as
i feel about graphene i don't know what
either does but i like it
you're a beautiful soul i love you i
love you
by the way one one thing when i'm when
i'm talking to like other like political
type people in dc and about about temple
they're like they're like yeah i like
tim i like there's this ian guy
like i don't i don't quite get what he
is i'm like well exactly
i was talking to michael and he was like
it took me a minute to figure out what
ian brought to the show but now i get it
yeah i was like all right cool
ian is the perfect foil for today i left
for two weeks i was like let's just give
it some time you know love what do they
say time heals all wounds
give it some space crossland
all right scotty says how do you think
the supreme court will rule on the stay
request for the vaccine mandates this
friday
well keep in mind that that stay
requests don't necessarily mean the
final ruling right that's just the
emergency injunction and so um unless
i'm i'm not tracking on something that i
think this is just the emergency
injunction and typically we've seen that
this supreme court now it depends it's
not the entire court that'll rule on it
it's just like which panel of judges
that you draw us i think it's three
um that they have not been ruling once
they have not been uh
continuing states so they have been
allowing the states to be able to be
able to run as they see fit and then
waiting for a full hearing
all right beefy says getter just blocked
tommy robinson's movie trailer called
the rape of britain so they're censoring
as well thoughts keep it the good work
that's usually how it starts is with
whites uh the supremic uh content like
it's okay to be without that white stuff
that that's because
i don't know
i remember that seeing a lot of
promotion for that on getter recently
and so it would surprise me that they
jesus you know
yeah
yeah tommy robinson's uh documentary i
haven't seen the trailer it's about
grooming gangs
oh wow yeah yeah i i hope it's not the
kind of thing where i mean that's his
whole visual career basically right when
they target a person like i was always
17. if someone
violates content you ban that account
but if they make a new account and they
choose not to violate the content
anymore then they're in the clear as
opposed to looking at tommy and like
wherever he is let's just try and whack
a multami it doesn't make any that's not
social you know it's anti-social it's
political men
all right nate carpenter says do you
think that these special ops people
killed the lady on january 6 only person
dead and we don't know who killed her um
that's not true though
we haven't yeah we do know the guy's
name now don't we i don't want to say it
because you know no no but i mean he's
been he's he was on uh 60 minutes i
believe he was on abc all right well
there you go he's saying yeah he's come
no he's come public um lieutenant i
can't think of his name but he's a
lieutenant though um the u.s capitol
police and he's he's come public someone
can remind me yeah he's the guy that
previously left the fire he left to fire
around a public
place
and it was the the interview was
horrific by the way like they had to
help him through the interview and he
was basically i mean he was saying stuff
about like i had you know i had to do
that you know she was gonna kill mike
pence she was gonna do all this stuff
that you know he couldn't possibly know
by looking at her and that he couldn't
possibly now he could say uh he could
have said a number of things but the
stuff that he was was saying in this
interview i mean it made him look
horrific it made him look really bad we
got a super chat from john paul diady he
says hey tim i'm also a 3d artist and
would love to support the cause youtube
name is accurate we also send an email
to spin the uh spin the ufo gmail.com
with your name and we'll get back to you
because we could use a 3d artist as well
but um probably more for like 3d
printing resin and abs and things like
that but uh you know we'll we'll take a
look and we'll see what's going on did
you guys see tommy robinson
car blown up outside
hotel eight hours ago yeah we we i think
i think we have an article on that so
you think he's being do you think he's
being targeted because of this
documentary he did yo they've been going
after this guy relentlessly i mean
they've been targeting thomas for years
yeah yeah man in and out of jail and all
the rest of it just and it's like they
locked him up for reporting on the case
yeah
he was he was it was like they were
about to issue a verdict or something
and he's outside the courtroom like oh
you're interfering with the trial so he
was i i remember that video by the way
he was he was filming himself yeah and
he was talking i believe it was facebook
and he was just talking to his phone
and they are out for that dude man
that's crazy
all right omega says tim there is no
such thing as establishment left right
means establishment and left means
counter establishment i cringe every
time that is not true that's completely
wrong someone's living in the 1950s yeah
seriously um no you're you're incorrect
sir uh with all due respect i appreciate
the super chat but you were wrong this
is why by the way every remake of
footloose will feature a christian
pastor right even though
even though we know that in the 1980s
christian pastors may over some small
towns of america had wielded that amount
of control the the plot of footloose is
that they're not allowed to you know
have rock dancing dancing it's forbidden
in the town and so they have to go just
outside the town limits to hold the the
prom and you know kevin bacon's there
carving burger kevin
um and so
the christian right hasn't had that
power in the united states for decades
right it the the left has been ascendant
by and far but it is completely the
origin story and ethos of the left to as
your comments are just say stated to be
we are the counter revolution we are the
counter revolutionaries we are the rebel
alliance we are the ones who are
fighting against against you when they
don't realize they won years ago they
won they are the establishment you are
the empire but the point is this is your
uh your music video yeah well language
is just how we describe concepts and
ideas you're not gonna convince that
you're not gonna you're not gonna be
speaking english if you call hassan you
know uh right wing they're gonna be like
what like well he's right wing because
he is establishment and he supports
establishment narratives and big
corporations so he's inherently
right-wing it's it's nonsensical like
when vosh says tim poole's a
conservative anybody who knows anything
about conservatives establishments
change that's literally not true like
that makes no sense establishments
change establishments left and right
mean many different things there's the
economic scale where left is cooperative
systems and right is competitive systems
and then you have the cultural scale
where far right means traditionalism and
far left means progressivism and then
there is the revolutionary scale which
is the left were revolutionary and the
right were status quo it means a variety
of different things so there you go you
also have um
the you know libertarians would would
describe it as you know totalitarian
versus anarchism
right yeah the up and the down there's a
bunch of different ways there's so many
different ways you could you could go
all right we got another one we got
another um
semantic statement dan
says stop using the word liberal to
refer to the democrats that word has a
root in the latin word for freedom and
the democrats are not are are not for
anything about freedom we need to take
that word back
crackpot authoritarian liberalists
i i i that's why i can't stand when
people say liberalism so the
the i the idea of being able to take
words back i think doesn't work i think
the way that
the but when a new term is placed into
the discourse it actually becomes a jump
ball
and the per the people who can
run to that one the fastest are the ones
who then claim it so the perfect
addition of this uh
there's two actually that i can think of
recently in the sort of linguistic
warfare that's out there number one is
fake news the term fake news was not
created by donald trump or anyone on the
right it's created by the washington
post and you know sort of milieu of
left-wing journalists who were using it
to describe people who were posting
stuff online like like luke or myself or
tim or basically everyone in this room
um during the election they said you are
fake news then the right stole that and
basically independence stole that and
used it to uh on
essentially mainstream media for the
remainder of history and they've been
destroyed the other one is let's go
brandon yeah right as silly as it is um
this was not something that was created
by the right and i think it's so
hilarious every time i see people try to
say this no it was created by an nbc
reporter right all right matthew says
hey y'all trying to escape the oregon
regime va mt or tx wife cannot finish
her degree in education without the jab
i need a decent paying state for
teaching and agriculture irrigation work
love y'all psf fauci yeah what do you
think which state is that uh was it uh
vermont montana or texas
well not vermont no that's not crazy
virginia no virginia yeah vermont's the
the number one most vaccinated state
va would be virginia right virginia i
wouldn't go to virginia where montana
maybe montana idaho yeah the challenge
so when we were looking at places to set
up i actually the first place i looked
was montana and wyoming yeah the problem
is infrastructure and so
if you get an airport we can fly people
wherever it's it's you know if you live
in the city you know that's the plot of
yellowstone
or it wasn't it was the plot of
yellowstone they they got to build a
company in wyoming uh montana montana
yeah but what kind of company well it's
it's um so it's done from the
perspective of a rancher who's fighting
against all the people
and that's and the rancher is
uh i heard it's really good it was until
this last season oh it just goes off the
rails totally off
all right
kevin costner's the lead but was so
really good until this year it's
actually fairly expensive it's not as
cheap as people think west virginia is
i think west virginia was better um
that's why we chose it because
there's big plots of land for low cost
and infrastructure is right there now we
had to get the cable lines installed the
fiber optic and that was really
expensive yeah so they came and actually
laid down the line buried it and then
had to connect it to the house which is
we'd hire a second company to do it took
like four months or whatever or here at
this place
mind if i ask and it's and i understand
if you can't say but but did the state
offer you anything for that because we
didn't ask them oh you but you i mean
they knew you were setting up a shop
here setting up a business as i mean the
owner well no one came and talked to us
and we didn't talk to anybody right
because in in other states virginia
though they will offer in other states
they will offer
oh right um they will offer you know tax
credits but only if you go in cities
right because they want to build up the
cities right you're out and we were up
to a lot up in alaska and i was talking
to a microbrewery about this that was
out you know sort of in one of the more
touristy areas and they were saying he's
like they don't give me anything man the
state they'll give me and the federal
government will give me all these
subsidies if i go and link in in the
grid and make the city bigger but if i
say no i want to run my business out
here in a rural area because i love this
area and i love serving these people i'm
on my own i'm gonna
gotta pay full free if the governor um
of west virginia would would work with
us to build like an off-grid on grid
hybrid setup where we can shut off free
domain stand of the grid and then turn
it put it back on we should actually um
you know
if you guys listening know anybody who
works in west virginia we're in um we're
near harper's ferry we're in so i won't
give out too much because we're
currently doing construction but we have
freedom stand we bought a big plots like
50 acres and um maybe maybe there's
something we can do because one of the
reasons i want to uh right now this
facility where is in maryland we're on
the border and then i live in west
virginia but we want to we're going to
set up our main big hub proud west
virginian tim pool absolutely proud
never thought i'd live in that state um
but there is opportunity
there's a ton of opportunity there and i
don't i don't think florida i think
florida has freedom i think texas has
freedom but i don't think there's much
opportunity because they're both very
over developed new hampshire is pretty
good
weather could be an issue and so we
ultimately settled on west virginia and
even in the panhandle there's a bunch of
opportunities did you definitely want to
be east coast
uh no no we were looking at wyoming and
montana okay but infrastructure was a
huge problem yeah so i was like in the
middle of nowhere extremely expensive
internet very little few roads if we did
do it uh setting up setting up there
we'd have to fly people in and have a
guest house for them instead of a hotel
or something depending on where we were
and then just internet in general is
very difficult now with starlink coming
in i was going to say starlink would
change that yeah but they're delayed we
were supposed to have starlink already
and they're like we'll get it to you at
some point next year so
but now um we've got a co we've got like
three different businesses elon's too
busy opening up factories in xinjiang we
got a new building being built 7 500
square feet three stories this is going
to be insane so it's uh 7 500 square
feet total space but then we're building
internal structures in a portion of it
for the new studio it's going to be
amazing the designs are insane and we're
gonna be hiring more people doing more
work doing more you know production and
i think this would be a huge opportunity
for the people who were near us in west
virginia for work it'll build up the
economy maybe we should reach out to you
that being said that being said i have i
there's a little beef between me and tim
that i should probably mention before we
get done here and speaking of building
new facilities because i would have
loved to show you the new facilities at
turning point usa out in phoenix
when we had america fest with 10
thousand screaming patriots crazy he's
huge who came out i don't know if you
saw any of the videos of that thing
that's where i was for ten days out in
phoenix dude we there there's three
buildings already right now out there
for turning point and they are expanding
wow and
that's cool so they got like a campus
it's it's a campus yeah it's essentially
well we're going to do that here in west
virginia and so we should we should
compare notes yeah yeah no absolutely so
we're going to have a zip line
yeah yeah no we are in inside the
building i went from here to turning
point
well what i want no it turns out
turning point should do because the
buildings are actually in pretty close
proximity we should have building to
building zip lines so you don't have to
go downstairs and walk across the
parking lot we're going to have the
studio is going to be in the second
floor
as like its own unique structure and the
whole back wall so like if you guys are
watching when you're seeing jack it's
gonna be glass and you're gonna look and
you're gonna be able to see the whole
production i want to be like a giant
wall of tvs and i'm just on that wall
all the time outside looking down on
people looking down on people
all right all right but but there's a
good feeling in the space
we think this might be up and running
within six months you wanna do one how
many words per minute are you typing
there bob one one-way glass so we can
see past no no people can watch it
people can look in and see the show we
actually used to have that at navy intel
um we had with like the control room
that was above and then you would have a
map of the world was behind you and then
any any incidents or if something was
going on that would flash up on the
world map and you could and then whoever
was running it whoever's like the
officer of the deck or if the captain
was around the ceo um you could or you
could say hey zoom in on that and then
that would be cool
it's like this coming in from new mexico
and it like zooms to the thing and then
it like zooms in and the story comes up
as he's explaining on the glass that's
that's exactly well we're not there yet
i'm just saying
there's all right let's read some more
we got tom tom bear says how about cern
getting fired up in march at three times
power get ready for the reality shift
folks it is coming we lost harambe last
time let's see what happened we lost
harambe we lost baron stain at ur
berenstein it's now berenstain we lost
uh you're gonna you're gonna be watching
the show and the next day ian's gonna be
super ripped and like three feet taller
right joke either no joke his hair's
gonna be short and he's gonna be like
this karate and yeah carrot top carrot
top that is crazy carrot top was he
always ripped like that no no that's
what's crazy about it
he normally looked like ian he was just
on rogan he said he was in vegas working
and making he had everything taken care
of so he just went nuts and started
working out three hours a day good for
him there you go
that's what some people in prison do
that
yeah
that's what the entertainment industry
is like pretty much
all right let's grab some super chats
fisheye studio says anyone notice luke
enunciates his words very thoroughly
such as against he hangs onto the sta
all the way through admirable but i
notice he flies through his words in
polish love you luke
okay
esl folks that's esl luke you you worked
out today you were saying before the
show we got a kickboxer trainer here um
and uh it was exhausting so i'm i'm
obliterated i'm tired i'm exhausted but
working on the high kick
a lot of different things
yeah don't you mean a lot of different
things i'll talk how i want
all right
now ian makes the show ten times better
love you dude
well there you go there you go that's
one magnitude oh i love you on the show
michael scott matthews says is giving
children harry potter names any less
cringe than giving children bible names
both works of fiction
cringe comment very good
let's see the basis of all of western
civilization versus a book about some
kids that go to magic school
it seems roughly equivalent
okay
yeah
all right where are we at
i don't know why this matters but um
rex says jon snow and egret are married
in real life that just makes me sorry
are they still married oh are they i
think i don't know i know they got it i
know they got married oh is that a
reference to the game peter dinklage
because peter dinklage said they wanted
the pretty white people to
oh did he say that he said people hated
it because they wanted the pretty white
people to like flee together or
something like that i don't know
something stupid i didn't say peter ding
i've i've heard that peter tinklage is
just a complete jerk in real life that
was a beautiful love story those two
like you could see them falling in love
while they were working together i
thought it's every once in a while you
see actors that happens with
good they lose it man
what's the guy's name oh kid harrington
yeah
i don't know anything all right kamikaze
says thanks for the great show tim
castenposo nascar just removed a let's
go brandon sponsorship for this year you
guys should contact brandon brown and
support his team in these trying times
support brandon
no no it's because the let's go brandon
coin uh was going to come in and then
because he wasn't able to get
sponsorships right and then so they're
canceling the sponsorship of let's go he
got canceled because of the meme so then
he's like okay i'll take this sponsor
let's go brandon coin and then they're
like no you can't do that
yeah nascar nascar has right of refusal
on all sponsorships so like so like you
can't have like you know they could you
know for like adult stuff or they have
their terms of service as well but no
that that's clearly you know clearly
politicizing but if this was by the way
if this was left-wing anything left-wing
that was coming in you know nascar would
let that in a hundred percent blm coin
all right exactly strider says i work at
kohl's today they announced they will be
following osha's ets which ets which
requires you to reveal vaccination
status and start weekly testing supreme
court is hearing arguments against this
on the 7th of january tyranny
i heard that uh starbucks was going to
be mandating all of their employees
and i was kind of wondering like
how how many employees do you think a
starbucks has
40 16 oh 40 40 i don't know
you guys agree 40 i don't know what
million no no no one starbucks location
oh just one starbucks 16 final answer 16
30 30 30. i was thinking about that i'm
like i wonder how much they make and if
i can go to the local starbucks out here
and be like anybody who doesn't want to
get the vaccine is going to be fired i
will hire you right now
we need baristas no no i should be like
i'll hire you same hourly rate and we'll
give you a guaranteed 40 hours a week
and you can just i don't know hold the
sign saying
fire from starbucks start from starbucks
and like you know i'll give you pure
blood guaranteed year of work or
whatever yeah there's got to be a way to
do that ethically
what's something how is it
wait what's unethical about that i will
pay you to hold up a sign saying i i
quit this job because of the vaccine
manage and i refused and then just hold
the sign and stand and then underneath
watch team guest irl yeah no i wouldn't
do that like i wouldn't want it to be
about me i'd be like here you go guys
guaranteed income you don't have to do
this you get one year because it really
doesn't make sense beyond that but you
have a year to figure figure things out
you'll keep getting paid and you've got
to make coffee no more customers all you
got to do is say i refuse to work under
these conditions
we could totally do that
tim is trying to start occupy starbucks
right now
that's what he's trying to do
he's coming full circle culture jamming
you know what are some clever ways to
engage in it's not even non-violent
disobedience it's just like protest
occupy starbucks like you know i wonder
you've got all these people uh you know
like joe rogan's got a big show but he's
not expanding his voice beyond his his
show comedy club that's the one thing
he's doing you were talking about on
your show right here no that i know but
i mean like the conversations he has the
very real news worthy conversations
comedy show is not going to do that
comedy show will will help for sure
but that voice he has on joe rogan's on
the jorgen experience won't expand
unless he puts money into it he doesn't
have to you know is he speaking at this
this rally that's coming up the um the
anti-mandates rally oh i don't think so
because i know i know mccullough and
uh malone are speaking and then they
mentioned that they have like some
secret celebrity speakers
right where is it it's in dc all right
it's coming at the end of january and
then what's what was it called again
because i remember seeing something
about this anti-mandate i know but it
was called something i forgot people
they haven't
they're going to be mad that i got it
wrong um i'm trying to remember what it
was i think brett weinstein speaking
defeat the mandates defeat the mandates
defeat the managed cc there you go and
um
and i remember when when malone
mentioned it on the podcast rogan
you know he kind of had like a
non-response response to it and so it
got me got me wondering if he was one of
one of the one of the celebrity speakers
no idea let's do uh let's do run one
that'd be wild that'd actually be wild i
was at the juggalo march by the way oh
yeah i remember the juggalo march that
was awesome they kicked out antifa
all right let's see happy little tree
says hey gang hey poso got another
dichotomy that we can use for this
current conflict assassins and templars
2021 and 2020 where 2020 and 2021 were
the years we found found out who is who
is that a reference to the video game or
like assassin
yeah warhammer accept everything about
the assassin's creed um history is
completely backwards but okay yeah but
no no let's be real the one thing that
got right was that the apple in the
bible was actually a reference to a
computer that contained a bunch of
information and the aliens it was alien
technology
right
sure sure have you guys played that game
that's the story that's that's that's
that's secret
we're not supposed to talk about that
all right we'll talk about that in the
subscriber hour ladies and gentlemen
um all right everybody i think the apple
was judgment by the way um one more
super chat ryan asks if we're putting an
event center at fredamaster judgment
prior to that we are one of the goals
we're going to have at fridamastan is
that if you are a member of timcast.com
at a certain level we've figured out yet
that we're going to actually have a like
you can apply to come and hang out on
friday nights and it'll be like 10
tickets per week this is what we wanted
to do here and we couldn't but the new
space will be able to and you'll be like
hanging at the bar and you can see the
show while we're doing it you'll hear it
and everything and hang out
candace owens does she has like um
you pay something but then she'll have
like a live audience i mean yeah when
i've done her show it's i mean it's like
ellen right you walk in and the whole
and then everyone's applauding and they
have like the little applause sign
and it's big audience too
electrifying all right everybody it it
adds something to the show it really
does don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to the channel and head
over to timcast.com become a member help
support our journalism but we're going
to have a members only segment posted
about around 11 or so p.m for all of you
guys so we greatly appreciate you can
follow the show tim cast ira basically
everywhere follow us on instagram where
we post clips you can follow me at tim
cast i'm on instagram as well i'm not i
twitter or whatever i like posting silly
things on instagram so follow me there
jack you want to show anything out yeah
jacksobic host of human events daily on
the turning point network
follow humid events we give you the
entire news that you need to know in
just 25 minutes a day it's just that
easy you don't listen for two hours you
don't listen for three hours just 25
minutes but if you do get a little bit
tired listening to those podcasts
if you get a little bit tired the best
way to recharge yourself
is that the best night's sleep in the
whole world available to you at
mypillow.com promo code posted here
those are awesome by the way my mom has
one everybody who got the gs promo code
so did you use promo code posto to get
your mother or my pillow in oh becky
someone yeah
someone someone tweeted i'd signed up
for a getter and i ha and i haven't seen
a post that wasn't an ad for my pillow
i was waiting for that michael i was
going to ask you i was like where's the
mic
but a lot i tell you what though a lot
of people by the way if you got a new
pie pillow for christmas and a lot of
people have new my pillows now because
we just had christmas make sure you run
it through the dryer once to activate
the patented fill this is something
there's a little card on the inside that
tells everyone to do this but not
everyone does because they're like i
don't need to read that i throw it out
like i was the guy that always read the
manual before i played the video game um
instead of like because i like the story
i like because there was a little bit of
a story in there
um
run it through there because i get a lot
of people saying hey man this pillow
like you should just be good but run it
through even even 15 minutes one cycle
is fine 15 minutes it it just fluffs it
up boom pops it up like a ballpark frank
i don't know a kid from chicago knows
about ballpark
i definitely don't believe in reading
the instructions beforehand and real men
don't do that but anyway when you're not
sleeping and and dozing off you could be
traveling expatting and also escaping as
i just released my travel expatting and
escaping hacking masterclass 50 never
before seen videos all available on
luconcensor.com i got a couple classes
on there i'm really proud of the video
that i did today talking about the el
salvadorian government
mandates that they just released with a
very funny important video to the
general public so i talked about in
great that about in great detail i'm
very proud of that video lukencensor.com
hope to see some of you guys there
thanks for having me follow me ian
crossland.net it's really good to be
back great to see you guys again um i
can confirm kit harrington and rose
leslie are married with the baby
congrats congrats for them and i want to
give a shout out to mike who i saw at
the redhorse diner in ellensburg
washington
if you're out there cool that you watch
the show good to see you matt it's weird
like for the first time i'm going out
and someone knew who i was
outside was very very casual very very
very normal i think this is just the way
it's going to be normal was it someone
who was like oh you're ian i can't stand
you on the show but i know you are man i
was talking about science hard before he
approached me too so you've been
listening for what mike thanks man good
to see you buddy and you guys may follow
me on twitter at sourpatchlist very glad
the gang's all back together and looking
forward to another great week we will
see you all at timcast.com 11 or so p.m
for members only sign up and we'll see
you all there
you